Ich möchte heute sprechen mit den beiden Autoren Ronald Reng und Tobias Escher, nicht nur über ihre Bücher zur WM 54, zur WM 74 und zur WM 2006, sondern generell auch zum Thema, wie erinnern wir uns eigentlich im Fußball an größere Ereignisse und wie berichtet man darüber. Jetzt gleich hier im Rasenfunk und los geht's.
Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Abgewehrt aus dem Hintergrund, müsste Ran schießen. Ran schießt. Müller und 2-1. Traumpass Müller. Und was gibt er?
Er gibt Elfmeter.
Er gibt Elfmeter. Ronny, ich nenn dich jetzt einfach Ronny, wenn es in Ordnung ist. Wir kennen uns ja jetzt schon ein bisschen. Ich hab das Gefühl, es hat gleich wieder Erinnerungen hervorgebracht bei dir. Hallo, willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Hallo Max, hallo Tobias. Ja, den 54er Sound kennt man definitiv. Den könnte ich auch aufwendig in der ähnlichen Intuition sagen. Den 2014er Sound kennen wir auch, aber den 74er habe ich nicht erkannt und hab mich zum einen erschreckt, wie komisch der geredet hat. Hab mich gefragt, war das die Radioübertragung oder war das tatsächlich im Fernsehen, dass der so halbleidenschaftlich geredet hat und sich halb zurückgehalten hat und plötzlich hat jemand Italienisch geredet. Das war mir jetzt auch nicht ganz klar, wo der her kam.
Ja gut, ich wollte nicht, dass wir zu rührselig werden, dass das jetzt jetzt hier nicht nur ein abgefeuert aller Weltmeistertitel wird. Außerdem hat ein mir bekannter Autor ja das Buch Der deutsche Sommer geschrieben, über das wir gleich noch sprechen wollen. Deswegen musste ja noch was von 2006 rein. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass ich bei 74 die DDR-Version erwischt habe. Zumindest war es nicht die, die man im Kopf hat. Tobi, bei dir hat es auch einiges ausgelöst und ich wette, also du kannst 54 auf jeden Fall mitsprechen, denn du hast es ja in deinem Buch auch sehr, sehr häufig zitiert. Schön, dass sie hier ist.
Das ist ja auch mit das bekannteste in die Richtung, was es gibt. Der Herbert Zimmermann Kommentar. Hallo erstmal an euch.
Und gleichzeitig sehen wir ja aber da schon eine Thematik, denn was ja viele zur WM 54 gar nicht mehr wissen, der ursprüngliche Fernsehkommentar, also das, was wirklich zu den Bildern gesprochen wurde, der ist nicht mehr erhalten. Der wurde irgendwann mal gelöscht, ist in keinem Archiv mehr verfügbar. Gesehen haben es ehrlicherweise damals auch nur wahrscheinlich so um die 10.000 Deutsche, glaube ich. In Westdeutschland sagt man immer so ungefähr, also Haushalte. Und deshalb ist der Radiokommentar im Nachhinein über die Bilder gelegt worden, was ja dann schon zeigt, manchmal konstruieren wir uns unsere Erinnerung so ein bisschen, oder?
Ganz stark bei diesen alten Fußballspielen. Bei von der WM 1954 gibt es ja die Übertragung nicht mehr. Die sind irgendwann bei der FIFA abgebrannt, was man da noch hatte, allen Fernsehübertragungen an Bildern. Und da gibt es nur so Rekonstruktionen der Spiele. Tatsächlich wurden sie damals im Fernsehen übertragen, wie du auch gesagt hast. Es gab zwar ein paar mehr als 10.000, weil es gab damals die ersten Public Viewing Formate, also dass Kneipen sich einen Fernseher angeschafft haben, noch ganz auf die Schnelle. Und dann haben die Leute dann sich dazu mit 30, 40 Leuten vor so einem wirklich 20 Zoll Gerät in Schwarz-Weiß gedrängt und dann die Bilder angeschaut. Das gab es ja auch damals neben der Radioübertragung. Aber ja, das ist natürlich eine Schwierigkeit, wenn man so ein Buch schreibt, dass man eben nicht mehr wie heute, wenn man auf Footballia zum Beispiel geht, das Portal, da kann man ja Spiele aus allen Ägiden angucken. Und ich kann es ja auch alles, was in den letzten 20 Jahren gespielt wurde, eigentlich angucken. Das gab es früher natürlich nicht.
Erstaunlich fand ich ja das, weil du sagst Erinnerungen, dass die Fußballspieler, vor allem die, die so in den 70er Jahren gespielt haben, wenn nicht die irgendwie, wenn das Thema kam auf 1954, dann wollen die alle vor dem Fernseher gesessen haben. Das fand ich schon damals immer erstaunlich, weil, wie du richtig sagst, es gab eigentlich kein Privatfernsehen. Also Jupp Heynckes, Bernd Hölzenbein, die haben fast identisch die Geschichte erzählt, wie sie von ihrem Vater losgeschickt wurden, schon drei Stunden vorher, um in die Kneipe zu gehen und sich hinzusetzen und den Platz zu reservieren für ihn. Wenn ich aber so in meinem Familienkreis gefragt habe, mein Onkel, mein Vater, die saßen alle vor dem Radio. Also da weiß ich schon nicht, ob dann selbst die Fußballer schon damals was besonderes waren oder ihre Nähe zum Fußball oder schon da die die Konstruktion der Erinnerung stattgefunden hat, dass man das so vermischt hat mit späteren Fußballereignissen oder vielleicht von anderen gehört hat, dass das Besondere damals war, in einer Gaststätte zu setzen und sich das so in die eigene Erinnerung geschlichen hat. Aber das ist was, was mir in der Tat aufgefallen ist bei denen, dass die alle vom Fernseher gesessen sein wollen.
Fußballer haben eine sehr eigene Erinnerung bei vielen Dingen. Da werden wir gleich, glaube ich, auch noch drauf kommen im Verlaufe dieses Gesprächs.
Ja, und interessant, weil die WM54 ja auch bei vielen Frauen ein ganz wichtiger Auslöser war für ihre eigene Fußballkarriere später. Das hat dann allerdings, da hat es dann jemanden wie Thorsten Körner gebraucht, der das in seinem Buch, Wir waren Heldinnen heißt das, glaube ich, sehr schön beschrieben hat, wo man eben aufsehen kann. Es war eigentlich ja fast logischerweise nicht nur für Jungen und für Männer, ein initialer Ereignis für ihre eigene Fußballkarriere, sondern auch für Frauen, die dann oft noch die viel interessantere Biografie hatten. Aber jetzt, wo ihr es sagt, da kommen auch relativ viele Fansäger vor in diesen Schilderungen. Also das zeigt sich schon, es ist nicht so ganz einfach, sich solchen historischen Stoffen zu widmen. Und jetzt habt ihr das ja eben, wie gesagt, ausführlich gemacht in euren Büchern. Ich lese nochmal die Titel vor, dass das auf jeden Fall schon mal erledigt ist. Also das Buch von Tobias Escher heißt Die Weltmeister von Bern, Biografie einer Jahrhundertmannschaft. Es erschienen bei Rowald. Alles wird natürlich verlinkt. Ah guck mal, Tobi hat auch sein Leseexemplar dabei. Das erkenne ich an den Post-its. Ronald Reng hat geschrieben unter anderem, 1974 eine deutsche Begegnung, als die Geschichte Ost und West zusammenbrachte. Das geht natürlich nicht nur über das Turnier, aber ich will jetzt auch nicht hier zu viel vorweggreifen. Und heute, am 2. April, erscheint der deutsche Sommer als 2006 plötzlich die Leichtigkeit ein Zog. Erschienen beides im PIPA-Verlag, wird natürlich verlinkt. Und die erste Frage, Ronny, geht dann mal an dich. Wie ist denn der Prozess bei dir, wenn du ein solches Buch schreibst? Womit beginnst du eigentlich?
Also bei dem Buch 1974 habe ich tatsächlich damit begonnen, das Spiel zu sehen, weil die Idee dieses Buches ist, anhand eines Tages, des 22. Juni 1974, versuchen die Atmosphäre damals, das Leben damals in beiden deutschen Staaten einzufangen. Das war der Tag, als zum einzigen Mal in der Geschichte die bundesdeutsche Nationalmannschaft gegen die DDR-Nationalmannschaft gespielt hat, bei der WM 74 eben. Und das war so die literarische Versuchsanleitung, schaffe ich das, rund um ein Spiel, das Leben damals einzufangen. Und da ging es tatsächlich damit los. Ich bin 1970 geboren. Ich habe null Erinnerungen an das Spiel. Ich habe es damals auch nicht gesehen, dieses Spiel zu schauen. Ja, weil es war das Rahmen des Buchs. Und dann sind mir auch einige Spieler aufgefallen, die ich als Fußballer interessant fand, dachte, die könnten meine Protagonisten werden. Also das große bundesdeutsche Thema war in diesem Spiel Günter Netzer. Es war, er saß auf der Ersatzbank, obwohl er für die Generation als der deutsche Mittelfeldspieler galt. Er wurde eingewechselt, die Bundesdeutschen verloren das Spiel 1 zu 0. Und er wurde zum Sündenbock gemacht. Also dieses Spiel waren die einzigen 20 Minuten, die Günter Netzer je bei einer Weltmeisterschaft gespielt hat. Da wurde aus dem Spiel heraus für mich dann schon klar, okay, diese Frage Netzer oder Oberath würde ich gern in dem Buch thematisieren. Und ja, das war so der Anfang dieses Spielschauen. Und dann ist der zweite Schritt eigentlich tatsächlich meistens Interviews machen, in dem Fall mit den Spielern. Und dann ergibt eins das andere. Dann erzählen mir die Spieler von vielleicht anderen interessanten Persönlichkeiten. Ich lese mich ein bei dem Buch 1974 war sehr viel Leserarbeit, sowohl Bücher als auch in den Archiven, Stasi-Archiv, Bundesarchiv, auch Polizeiachive, um eben Fakten zu sammeln. Und irgendwann waren dann drei Jahre um und das Buch war fertig.
So schnell können drei Jahre vergehen. Und Tobi, bei dir war natürlich die Problematik schon mal das Sehen von Spielen. Deckt sich denn der Prozess von Ronny mit deinem? Also hast du auch beim Spiel selbst begonnen?
Nein, tatsächlich nicht. Also die Idee für mein Buch zu 54 kam ja noch mit einem anderen Buch, das ich geschrieben habe. Ich habe ja mal die Geschichte der Taktik im deutschen Fußball geschrieben. Und das ist ja dann eher eine oberflächere Arbeit als das, was Ronald da geleistet hat. Weil da ging es ja wirklich darum, 150 Jahre zusammenzufassen. Und dann hast man ja auch mit den Spielen anbegefangen tatsächlich. Also damals habe ich dann wirklich mir so eine Festplatte mit 100 Spielen gemacht, die großen Spiele der deutschen Fußballgeschichte und die geschaut und dann daraus versucht, die gesamte Geschichte des deutschen Fußballs so taktisch anzuarbeiten. Und dann gehst du halt in die Quellen rein, auch natürlich nicht ganz so tief, wie du es dann bei anderen Sachen tun kannst, wenn du 150 Jahre abdecken musst. Und da bin ich dann relativ stark an 54 hängen geblieben, weil das einfach so eine schöne Geschichte war. Und ich glaube, der große Unterschied zu Ronald und mir ist, also bei meinem Thema gab es schon zig Bücher. Das bin ich da ganz offen und ehrlich. Das ist nicht so, dass ich da jetzt ein Erstlingswerk gemacht habe. 54 ist eine sehr, sehr gut erforschte Geschichte im deutschen Fußball. Aber auch die Protagonisten sind alles im Tod. Also die Protagonisten sind mittlerweile alle verstorben. Und da ist es dann natürlich nicht mehr möglich, Zeitzeugen in dem Maße zu befragen, weil die Zeitzeugen, die noch leben, haben eine sehr verschobene Erinnerung. Weil die waren dann häufig Kinder zu der Zeit, als sie das Spiel gesehen haben. Wie er es dann ja gerade schon angedeutet hatte, heißt es dann häufig, ich habe das Spiel gesehen oder ich habe das Spiel im Fernseher gesehen. Wo man dann auch bei kleinerer Recherche hinkommt, naja, wenn du da in diesem Dorf aufgewachsen bist, dann hattest du da keinen Empfang. Dann kann das gar nicht sein, dass du dieses Spiel im Fernsehen gesehen hast. So, weil das war auch gar nicht so, dass überall schon halt wirklich Empfang möglich war zu dieser Zeit. Und dann bist du dann dementsprechend eher dabei, Quellen zu checken, halt in verschiedenen Archiven zu sein, in Kaiserslautern im Archiv, in Essen im Archiv war ich dann sehr viel unterwegs, hier in Hamburg, in Berlin, und da dann entsprechende Geschichten zu prüfen.
Wobei, ich glaube, wir müssen schon sagen jetzt, wo wir anfangen, unseren Zeitzeugen gar nicht mehr zu trauen. Also das ist völlig richtig, dass sich die Erinnerung verfälscht. Es ist trotzdem, finde ich, ganz, ganz wichtig als Buchautor, wenn man es noch machen kann. 1954, wie gesagt, kann keiner mehr die Zeitzeugen befragen, die Spieler. Aber wenn man es machen kann, dann muss man das, finde ich, unabdingbar machen, weil man einfach nur so noch etwas Neues erfährt. Man muss es dann immer so gut wie möglich überprüfen, was sich zum großen Teil auch überprüfen lässt dann mit Fakten, indem man auch andere Leute befragt. Und oft wird man dann natürlich auch widersprüchliche Erinnerungen haben. Mir fällt ein, bei meinem 2006er-Buch haben Bertie Vogts und Jürgen Klinsmann konträr erzählt, wer eigentlich auf die Idee von ihnen beiden kam, dass Jürgen Klinsmann Bundestrainer werden soll. Die beiden haben sich also getroffen im Sommer 2004 in Amerika. Das ist ein Fakt offenbar. Sie haben zusammengegrillt. Das glaubt man ihnen auch. Und in Jürgen Klinsmanns Version kam dann Bertie Vogts auf die Idee. Du musst Bundestrainer werden. Und in Bertie Vogts Version kam Jürgen Klinsmann darauf oder hat ihm quasi es nahegelegt? Frag doch mal du für mich beim DFB an. Ich finde, solche Sachen muss man dann schildern. Und das ist ja dann teilweise auch schön für den Leser nachzuvollziehen. Wir erinnern uns gerne so, dass es für uns auch einen Vorteil hat oder vielleicht angenehmer ist, dass Jürgen Klinsmann sich nicht erinnert. Ich habe mich da aufgedrängt, sondern ich bin da quasi ins Spiel gebracht werden. Aber nur so kann man natürlich auch noch noch neue Dinge erfahren. Wie, also 2006, wie lief das eigentlich zum Beispiel ab, dass David Odonkor nominiert wurde, was damals für alle ein Flash war, eine Überraschung war. Und ja, von daher muss man, finde ich, wo es geht, die Leute befragen. Das ist auch für mich als Autor eigentlich das Interessanteste daran. Also darauf bin ich auch besonders neugierig. Aber man muss immer im Hinterkopf haben, dass wir uns gerne so erinnern, dass es für uns angenehm ist.
Man muss ja auch dazu sagen, wenn ich jetzt, wenn man in die Archive geht zum Beispiel und dann die alte Ausgaben des Kickers, alte Ausgaben des Sportmagazins, alte Ausgaben der Sportillustrierten liest, sind das ja auch im Endeffekt die Erinnerung von den Reportern, die da vor Ort waren, die das Spiel halt vor Ort gesehen haben, den du dann natürlich auch um gewisse Maße vertrauen musst. Und beim Beispiel 1954, ich habe gerade mal erlegt, ich glaube, es gibt fünf Autobiografien von Spielern, die bei der deutschen Nationalmannschaft auf dem Platz standen. Und diese Autobiografien sind dann natürlich die Erzählung von den Spielern. Und dann gibt es da aber auch Sachen, die einfach widersprüchlich sind. Das ist dann auch klar natürlich in der Natur der Wahrnehmung, weil natürlich die Spieler das unterschiedlich wahrnehmen. Aber es steckt da natürlich unfassbar viel drin. Dennoch habe ich, ich glaube, da kann jeder Sportjournalist kennt, hat solche Geschichten, wo ich mal mit einem Spieler, der noch gar nicht so alt ist, über ein altes Spiel, wo ich selber am Stadion war und diskutiert habe, und jemand dann brühwarm erzählt hat, dass er in dem Spiel zwei Tore geschossen hat. Und ich war selber da und ich habe mich auch gar nicht daran erinnert, dass er zwei Tore geschossen haben will. Und dann, als ich zu Hause geguckt habe, kam halt raus, er hat ein Tor geschossen. Und im Endeffekt habe weder ich mit meiner er hat kein Tor geschossen, noch er mit seiner er hat zwei Tore geschossen Erinnerung recht gehabt. Also man muss da natürlich dann immer natürlich gegenchecken. Aber diese Geschichten dann hinter den Kulissen sind ja auch das, was, wie Ronny gesagt hat, das Salz in der Suppe gibt.
Ja, und mir fällt gerade ein, wenn du sagst, denn man muss natürlich auch die Zeitungsberichte mit anständiger Vorsicht genießen. Da fällt mir ein ganz kleines Detail an. Bei dem 74er Buch hatte ich, wie gesagt, Wolfgang Overath als einer meiner Protagonisten dann ausgewählt. Und dann fand ich im Kicker, dass er vor der Weltmeisterschaft zusammen mit dem Athletiktrainer vom 1. FC Köln in Urlaub gefahren sei, um sich fit zu machen. Super interessantes Detail. Dann habe ich ihn drauf angesprochen. Und dann sagt er zu mir, was? Nee, ich fahre doch nicht mit dem Trainer in Urlaub. Ich war immer mit meiner Frau in Urlaub, und zwar immer in Sardinien. Und in dem Fall habe ich tatsächlich der 50 Jahre später getätigten Zeitzeugenaussage mehr geglaubt. Weil ich glaube, dass selbst Wolfgang Overath sich im Normalfall daran erinnert, mit wem er im Urlaub gewesen ist. Und dass halt auch der Kicker damals vielleicht das aus zweiter Hand erfahren hat von Mannschaftskameraden oder sonst was, der vielleicht gesagt hat, ich glaube, der Overath hat sogar den Fitnesstrainer mit gehabt im Urlaub. Also auch manchmal muss man da abwägen, und dann habe ich es einfach rausgelassen. Das war in dem Fall das sichere Beispiel. Und so muss man sich als Autor quasi immer vortasten, auch seiner eigenen Abwägung dann vertrauen, die selbstverständlich auch mal falsch sein kann. Was übernimmt man für Fakten oder Behauptungen und was nicht.
Hattet ihr mal den Fall, dass jemand sich an etwas offenbar nicht erinnern wollte? Also ein Beispiel dafür, als ich meinen Podcast und Buch zu Elf Leben zu Uli Hoeneß gemacht habe. Es gibt dokumentiert in zwei Interviews und drei Artikeln aus der, ich glaube aus dem Jahr 2010, die kurze Episode, wo er DFL-Präsident werden wollte, wo er dazu zwei Interviews gegeben hat. Und es wurde dann noch insgesamt, also insgesamt waren es, glaube ich, fünf Artikel, die ich dazu hatte, in zwei unterschiedlichen Medien. Das heißt, es war gut dokumentiert. Plus es haben mir auch andere Gesprächspartner gesagt, Dinge gesagt, die ich leider nicht zitieren durfte, die sich darauf bezogen haben. Und Uli Hoeneß hat aber später mir gegenüber, noch nicht so doll, aber dann in einem anderen Podcast, der ihn darauf angesprochen hat, hat er einfach gesagt, nee, ich wollte nie DFL-Präsident werden. Jetzt hatte natürlich dann der entsprechende Podcaster nicht meine Quellen und konnte da nicht nachhaken. Aber da habe ich mich gefragt, ja, wie hätte ich damit dann umgehen sollen? Also ich glaube, ich habe es okay gemacht, weil ich habe halt dann mich nur auf die Quellen bezogen und hatte ja auch kein direktes Zitat von ihm. Aber Tobi, was machst du mit Menschen, die sich an etwas nicht erinnern wollen vielleicht auch? Schildert man dann das, weil das ja auch etwas aussagt? Oder wie geht man damit um?
Tatsächlich bin ich noch nie persönlich in den Fall gekommen, dass irgendjemand mir gegenüber was nicht sagen wollte. Aber da ist, glaube ich, auch Ronald der bessere Ansprechpartner mit den vielen Interviews, die er für seine Bücher geführt hat. Was natürlich beim 54er-Fallen ein berühmt-berüchtigtes Beispiel ist, ist die Doping-Geschichte. Also es gibt ja Vorwürfe, dass die 454er-Mannschaft mit Pervitin gedopt haben soll. Und diese Vorwürfe kamen aber schon damals relativ kurz nach dem Turnier auf, weil nämlich bei der deutschen Mannschaft es relativ viele Fälle von Hepatitis gab. Und es kam auch relativ schnell dann klar war, dass diese Hepatitis-Fälle nur über eine Ansteckung mit einer Spritze zustande gekommen seien. Und im Nachgang, wenn man dann auch die Quellen dann im Nachgang checkt und auch die Interviews, die die Spieler dann geben mussten, wird relativ freimütig zugegeben, dass gespritzt wurde. Also dass da tatsächlich gespritzt wurde, aber man hat halt behauptet, es wurde Vitamin C gespritzt. Also man hat Injektionen mit Vitamin C bekommen. Und da ist das Beispiel, dass Ottmar Walter auch in einem solchen Rahmen, ich meine, es war der Kicker oder sowas, auch offen sagt, ja, wir haben diese Spritzen bekommen. Interessanterweise kam dann über Forscher, das Thema ist dann 50 Jahre später noch mal hochgekocht, 2004 zum 50-jährigen Jubiläum der WM 1954. Und da kam das dann in die Bildzeitung. Die Bildzeitung hat dann diese große Geschichte aufgegriffen, so von wegen unsere Helden von Bern alle gedobt. Und da sagt dann Ottmar Walter plötzlich, nee, wir haben nie Spritzen bekommen. Ich habe mich nicht daran erinnern können, wo er dann ja aber ganz offen nachweisen kann. Du hast aber 1954 damals das deutlich anders wahrgenommen. Du warst ja auch zweimal zur Kur mit der Hepatitis. Du warst da ja von auch betroffen. Ob das wirklich Doping war oder Vitamin C, das wird sich wahrscheinlich nie aufklären. Aber dass gespritzt wurde, ist halt offen gewesen. Aber 50 Jahre später wollen dann die deutschen Spieler davon nichts mehr gewusst haben.
Was natürlich klar zeigt, dass die Erinnerung auch immer ausgelegt wird, je nachdem, mit was du gerade konfrontiert wirst. In diesem Fall, so wie du es schilderst, würde ich ganz klar sagen, dass sie irgendetwas Gespritste bekommen haben, scheint offensichtlich. Und wenn sich 50 Jahre später Otmar Walter als Reaktion auf eine Anklage der Bild-Zeitung nicht mehr erinnern will, dann glaube ich, dann ist das dann doch eher ein Ausflug, was man jetzt dann nicht unbedingt in ein Buch aufnehmen muss.
Nee, beziehungsweise man muss beides aufnehmen vielleicht. Also man muss da auch diese Ambivalenz aufnehmen, wie man natürlich mit Geschichte auch umgeht. Weil wir haben ja einmal dann im 1954er, ist das ja Gegenwart noch. Also das ist ja wirklich Gegenwartsgeschichte, wenn man so möchte. Und 50 Jahre später ist es eine Erinnerung an ein Ereignis, dass er selbst schon Geschichte geworden ist und dass er selbst schon einen mythischen Klang bekommen hat. Das ist ja auch eine Frage von Rezeptionsgeschichte, um das mal so zu bezeichnen.
Ja, ist die Frage, wie du es schilderst. Also wenn du dein Buch aus dem Jahr 1954 herausschildern willst, dann würde ich solche nachträglichen Rechtfertigungen vielleicht gar nicht mal aufnehmen. Weil es für mich so offensichtlich ist, dass das jetzt noch nicht mal der Versuch ist, sich ordentlich zu erinnern, sondern sozusagen etwas zu vertuschen. Aber natürlich kann man es auch genauso dem Leser schildern. 50 Jahre später wollte Ottmar Walter davon nichts mehr wissen. Also gibt es auch andersherum bei den Olympischen Spielen 1936. In der Viermalhundertmeterstaffel der Amerikaner wurden einen Tag vor dem Rennen in Berlin, im Nazi-Deutschland damals, die zwei jüdischen Hundertmetersprinter aus der Staffel gestrichen. Ist bis heute ein Mysterium, wurden die aus politischen Gründen gestrichen, weil man sich quasi vor Hitler verneigen wollte. Und beide jüdische Sprinter haben damals gesagt, nein, es war eher etwas Vereinspolitisches, dass der Selektor, also der Nationaltrainer, wollte zwei Sprinter, die er selber trainiert hat, in die Mannschaft reinholen, in die Staffel. Und 50, 60 Jahre später ist einer dieser jüdischen Sprinter, Martin Klückmann, ist es plötzlich aus ihm herausgebrochen. Das war damals nur, weil ich Jude war. Man hat mich Hitler geopfert und so was. Und das, finde ich, muss man dann reinschreiben. Und das muss man auch offen lassen, wie es war. Aber auch da liegt für mich nahe, dass er selber offenbar 50 Jahre darüber nachgedacht hat, immer wieder damit konfrontiert wurde, war es damals, durftest du nicht laufen, weil du Jude warst. Und sich das vielleicht dann auch in der Erinnerung bei ihm so verfestigt hat, er sich in diese Opferrolle selber rein erinnert hat. Aber das sind tatsächlich dann Fälle, große Fälle, die nicht mehr zu klären sind, auch für ein Autor. Und der größte Fehler, glaube ich, den man als Autor machen kann, und das machen durchaus viele, ist dann einfach, sich für eine Version entscheiden, ganz klar. Viele machen das vielleicht, weil sie sich selber überzeugern oder weil sie die eine Version spektakulärer finden. Und da finde ich es ist immer eigentlich spannender, auch wenn man dem Leser dann selber mit diesem Rätsel zurücklässt. Wie war das denn 1954 wirklich mit dem Doping? Ich habe die und die Indizien, die Tobias Escher für mich zusammengetragen hat. Und dann kann der Leser selber überlegen. Das ist auch eine Art von Souveränität als Autor, finde ich.
Ist das dann auch der Grund, Ronny, warum du in dem 74er und dem 2006er-Buch Fußnoten verwendet hast? Denn du hast ja schon unzählige Bücher geschrieben. Bist ja der Rekordmeister des Fußballbuches des Jahres, kann man glaube ich so sagen. Sehr viele ohne Fußnoten, aber eben genau diese beiden haben sehr viele Fußnoten, weil man eben manchmal noch so eine Ergänzung machen muss, die aber nicht wichtig genug für den Text ist. Oder warum hast du das gemacht?
Also erstmal klingt Rekordmeister schrecklich für mich, so nach Bayern München. Damit will ich nichts zu tun haben.
Du bist der Pep-Gardione des Fußballbuches des Jahres.
Das klingt besser, das klingt besser, ja. Na, es sind zwei Gründe. Der eine ist, glaube ich, dass diese beiden Bücher, so hoffe ich doch, geschichtlich relevanter sind. Also es geht hier vielmehr auch um gesellschaftliche Themen als jetzt zum Beispiel in der Robert-Enke-Biografie oder in der Miraclose-Biografie. Der zweite Grund ist, dass ich vielmehr mit Quellen gearbeitet habe, als in den Büchern. Die anderen Bücher sind ja alle eigentlich eher Zeit, also Spiele in unserer Zeit. Da habe ich hauptsächlich mit Tageszeitungen gearbeitet und natürlich mit Interviews vor allem. Also waren mehr orale, wie sagt man, mündliche Geschichte. Und der dritte Grund ist aber, dass ich auch mir einbilde, dass sich da der Anspruch der Leser gewandelt hat. Also die Bücher, sagen wir mal, das Robert Enke Buch oder auch mein allererstes Buch 2002 geschrieben, der Traumhüter, das war in einer Zeit, da war eher der Anspruch an den Autor, er soll versuchen, die Geschichte so direkt wie möglich zu erzählen, dass der Leser voll in der Geschichte drin ist und das stören Fußnoten nur. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass er bei heute viel mehr gefragt ist, also Transparenz, wo hast du das her, dass das auch von der Leserschaft viel mehr gefordert wird. Vielleicht dadurch, dass es einfach auch zugänglicher ist, durch digitale Medien und vielleicht auch durch diesen Spiegelskandal mit dem Schreiber Relotius, der hieß, also dass sozusagen ein größeres Misstrauen gegenüber Autoren ist. Also ich habe es so gespürt, wenn ich zum Beispiel an der Reportagenschule den Reutlingen Klassen gehalten habe, über Sachbuch schreiben, dass dann viel mehr, weil auch von den Schülern die Frage kam, wo haben sie denn das her? Also viel mehr eine Forderung nach Quellen. Das ist so der dritte Grund. Also gesellschaftliche Relevanz haben diese Bücher mehr. Zum anderen, ich habe viel mehr mit schriftlichen Dokumenten gearbeitet und drittens, es ist ein neues Zeitphänomen, würde ich sagen.
Was ja interessant ist, weil das erfordert ja auch ein nicht anderes Arbeiten, denn man sollte schon vorher faktenbasiert mit vielen Quellen und so weiter gearbeitet haben, aber ein anderes Schreiben. Und man kommt dann ja auch automatisch näher an ein wissenschaftliches Schreiben heran. Und Tobi, man landet ja letztlich bei deinem Buch hast du zum ersten Mal, wenn ich das richtig weiß, im Grunde wie ein Historiker gearbeitet. Hast du dich vorher damit auseinandergesetzt, wie das eigentlich funktioniert? Welche Standards man da zum Beispiel erfüllen muss?
Ich möchte jetzt nicht lügen, also nicht großartig. Nein, also natürlich, ich bin, was vieles angeht, autodidakt. Und ich habe jetzt auch keinen Anspruch darauf, dass das eine historische Arbeit ist. Es ist immer noch populär Lektöre. Es ist immer noch für den Massenmarkt gedacht. Es ist immer noch dafür gedacht, dass die Leute da in erster Linie es in ihrer Freizeit lesen und dann eben die Geschichte mitnehmen. Ich habe auch Fußnoten drin und ich habe auch immer versucht, alles, was ich da an Behauptung habe und auch, wenn ich mal eine Position übernommen habe, dann habe ich auch immer versucht, über Fußnoten dann zu sagen, ja, aber es gibt dann noch diese Alternativposition, wenn man dann in das und das reinschaut. Da dann schon der Versuch, dieses wissenschaftliche Arbeiten, was man ja auch an der Universität mitbringt. Aber ich bin jetzt kein Geschichtswissenschaftler. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt bei jedem einzelnen, bei jeder einzelnen These könnte ich jetzt nicht genau geschichtswissenschaftlich mit drei Quellen belegen. Das da steht da, da steht da und die beziehen sich nicht aufeinander. Das muss ich ganz ehrlich gestehen. Das ist auch nicht der Anspruch, finde ich, für jemanden, der ein Buch für den Massenmarkt schreibt.
Also ich glaube, populärwissenschaftlich ist wahrscheinlich der richtige Ausdruck für diese Bücher. Tobias hat es völlig richtig beschrieben. Eine Belegbarkeit muss da sein. Ab und an sind wahrscheinlich auch Quellen drin, die sogar für Wissenschaftler interessant sind. Also bei mir, bei dem Buch über die Bundesrepublik und die DDR habe ich sicher Sachen aus dem Archiv der Staatssicherheit verknüpft mit Zeitzeugen, Aussagen, die wahrscheinlich noch nicht so bekannt waren drin. Aber im Großen und Ganzen habe ich mich jetzt auch nicht an den Anforderungen einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit orientiert. Ich glaube, die Lesbarkeit für den, in Anführungszeichen, normalen Leser steht dann doch im Vordergrund bei solchen Büchern.
Ich weiß ja auch mein guter Freund Tim Rieke, der ja bei Spielverlagerung damals mit einer Blogger war, aber auch schon öfter hier beim Rasenfunk zu Gast. Der ist ja Historiker. Und wenn du dir das in Arbeit liest, ist es ein ständiges entweder oder. Also es ist ständig so, da steht das und da steht das und da steht das. Und man hat natürlich aber auch, wenn man so ein Buch dann schreibt, möchte man ja auch einen Lesefluss drin haben. Man möchte ja eine Geschichte erzählen. Man hat ja eine gewisse Dramaturgie, die man ja auch erfüllen möchte. Erzählte Geschichte ist ja auch immer erzählte Geschichte. Da macht man natürlich dann immer so auch manchmal die Erfahrung, dass Wirklichkeit und erzählte Wirklichkeit nicht dasselbe sind, sondern dass die Wirklichkeit häufig komplexer ist als die erzählte Wirklichkeit, mit dem man in eine Dramaturgie auch pressen möchte. Da sind dann Fußnoten sehr gut. Ich hatte ein Feedback von einem Leser, der meinte, ja, die Fußnoten sind viel interessanter als das eigentliche Buch. Weil dann da natürlich dann all die ganzen... Ja, ja, das war schon ein interessantes Feedback. Da habe ich dann ganz viele von diesen Nebengeschichten reingepackt, wo man weiß, okay, wenn ich die jetzt da noch reinwerfen würde als eigentliche Buch, wird das total den Lesefluss stören. Aber es ist so eine interessante Geschichte. Die wollte ich dann doch noch mal ausgepackt haben. Oder hier. Dann muss man auch die Auswahl treffen. So Spieler A sagt, es war so, Spieler B sagt, es war so. Also Fritz Walter und Helmut Rahn haben sich ein Zimmer geteilt bei der WM 54. Der eine sagt, es war so. Der andere sagt, es war so. Und der Geschichtswissenschaftler würde jetzt entweder oder schreiben und dann noch die ganzen mit ganz viel konjunktiv dann gucken. Okay, wir sind über zwei Erzählungen. Und als Autor hat man dann manchmal das Glück, sagen zu können, okay, das finde ich jetzt die schönere Anekdote, die nehme ich rein, auch wenn sie vielleicht beim Fritz Walter nicht drin steht, wie sie bei Helmut Rahn drin steht.
Ja, interessant. Du hast ja dann auch da so diesen personalisierten Erzähler, dadurch, dass du genau auf die Charaktere guckst. Das macht es ja ein bisschen leichter. Aber das zeigt ja auch, wie man sich an sowas heranarbeiten muss und wie wichtig letztlich Gesprächspartnerinnen für das eigene Schreiben sind. Und da ist mir bei dir aufgefallen, Ronny, dass du wirklich ein breites Feld bespielst. Also du hast mit einem Astronauten gesprochen, Thomas Reiter. Du hast mit Christoph Heusgen gesprochen, das war der Sicherheits- und außenpolitische Berater Angela Merkel. Du hast mit einem Geschäftsmann gesprochen, der Camps zur WM 2006 aufstellen wollte für die WM 74. Also für das Buch hast du mit einem ehemaligen RAF-Terroristen gesprochen, mit dem Schauspieler Matthias Brandt und so weiter und so fort. Nach welchen Kriterien wählst du aus und wie viele Absagen kommen auf eine Zusage mit dir zu sprechen?
Also bei dem Buch 2006 geht es ja darum, nicht das Zeitgefühl einzufangen. Die Ursprungsidee war, ich würde in Gesprächen mit Freunden kommen so oft, gerade in der jetzigen Zeit, wo sind wir jetzt und überleg doch mal, wie schön es 2006 war, wie sehr die Völkerverständigung da im Vordergrund stand. Deswegen war meine Grundidee bei diesem Buch, dieses Zeitgefühl zu überprüfen. Wie war es denn wirklich 2006? Und das Nebenthema war sozusagen, zu überprüfen, war, was Jürgen Klinsmann damals gemacht hat, für den deutschen Fußball tatsächlich so revolutionär. Also es ist vordergründig eigentlich ein Buch über ein Zeitgefühl, über ein Lebensgefühl und beiläufig sozusagen ein Fußballbuch, wobei es wahrscheinlich 40 Prozent über Fußball geht. Und deswegen diese große Auswahl an oder diese Breite an verschiedenen Gesprächspartnern. Ich habe tatsächlich versucht, die damaligen Themen in dem Buch unterzubringen. Also zum Beispiel auch der Afghanistan-Krieg. Da gab es dann die Verbindung, dass Jürgen Klinsmann mit drei, vier Soldaten während der Weltmeisterschaft über Video geredet hat und die gefragt hat, wie erlebt ihr denn in Afghanistan die WM? Und dann konnte ich quasi nach Afghanistan auch abschwenken, weil das damals ein sehr wichtiges Thema war. Zum ersten Mal die Bundeswehr in einem Krieg wirklich vor Ort verwickelt. Und ja, wie viele Absagen kommen? Ich hätte jetzt spontan gesagt gar keine. Das stimmt wahrscheinlich nicht. Da erinnere ich mich wahrscheinlich. Daran will ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern. Ich bin schon sehr hartnäckig auch und frage sehr oft nach. Natürlich kamen Absagen 2006. Es kamen Absagen von Angela Merkel, von Gerhard Schröder, der plötzlich behauptet hat, er ist krank. Und interessanterweise vielleicht für euch von Jürgen Klopp. Weil der sich nicht mehr so gerne an 2006 erinnert. Also wir erinnern uns noch, er war eigentlich der Star des Sommers oder ein Star des Sommers, weil er das Fernsehen völlig verändert hatte. Er war ein junger, relativ für die Masse unbekannter Bundesligatrainer von Mainz 05 und hat im ZDF zusammen mit Urs Maier und mit Johannes B. Kerner Fernsehen ganz neu gemacht. Viel lockerer, viel fachlicher vor allem. Es wurde zum ersten Mal anders über Fußball geredet, also so, wie ihr jetzt über Fußball redet. Quasi die Mutter von euch war Jürgen Klopp und der wollte aber nicht mehr mit mir reden, weil er damals, weil er keine nicht unbedingt gute Erinnerung an diesen Sommer hat. Er hat das Gefühl gehabt, dass er damals nicht mehr als Fußballtrainer wahrgenommen wurde, sondern als der, der schön über Fußball redet. Und in seiner Eigenwahrnehmung wollte er nichts mehr als ein ganz erfolgreicher, toller Fußballtrainer sein. Und er hatte das Gefühl, dass sogar selbst Borussia Dortmund ihn dann ein Jahr später vor allem wegen seiner Außendarstellung, wegen seiner Ausstrahlung geholt hat und nicht unbedingt inhaltlich. Und ja, deswegen musste ich auf ihn verzichten. Ich habe aber mit Urs Maier geredet, der dann wahrscheinlich lustigere Sachen über Jürgen Klopp erzählt hat, als die Jürgen Klopp selber erzählt hätte. Also da habe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt den Verlust gespürt im Buch. Aber ich fand es auch interessant, gerade bei dem Thema, mit dem wir begonnen haben, in Erinnerungen, also hier wollte sich jemand mal nicht erinnern.
Und gleichzeitig schreibt ihr ja deshalb diese Bücher über diese Momente, weil sie so eine besondere Bedeutung haben. Zumindest in einem kleinen Teil der Gesellschaft, beziehungsweise ihr habt euch jetzt auf die großen Themen gestürzt. Da kann man dann eben wirklich Parallelen ziehen zur Gesellschaft, jenseits von nur Sport. Dabei gibt es aber natürlich, Tobi, die große Gefahr, Dinge zu verklären oder ein Narrativ zu formen. Also mein Eindruck ist, es ist mir so bei meiner eigenen Arbeit aufgefallen, es ist gar nicht so, dass es vom Beginn an das gleiche Narrativ ist, sondern es kann auch so sein, ich glaube 54 ist ein bisschen anders, dass es sich erst so langsam verformt und dann in der Rückschau, wenn so zehn Jahre nachdem ein wichtiges sportliches Ereignis war, dann kommen die ersten Erinnerungen daran und 20 danach dann die ersten Bücher. Und dann auf einmal werden ganz viele Dinge in ein sportliches Ereignis hineingelesen, die vielleicht gar nicht drinstecken. Die WM 2014 ist für mich ehrlicherweise ein sehr, sehr gutes Beispiel dafür. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass wir in fünf Jahren nicht mehr sagen werden, dass das das Ergebnis der Nachwuchsleistungszentren war. Und aber die erste Interpretation dieses Ereignisses war so. Wie kann man dem denn als Autor begegnen? Und ist das überhaupt schlimm oder oder ist quasi gerade der Reiz, an ein solches Narrativ aufzusetzen mit einem eigenen Buch?
Also man schreibt ja so eigentlich ein Buch nie in einen leeren Raum hinein, sondern du hast es ja gerade schon beschrieben. Das gibt ja von allen Ereignissen schon Interpretationen, allein dadurch, dass Fußball so populär ist und dass Millionen Menschen ja auch erlebt haben. Also es ist ja gelebte Geschichte in vielen Fällen. Es ist keine Hinterzimmergeschichte, wo man dann in der Politik dann nochmal ganz viele neue Dinge aufdenken kann. Das kann man dann im Verlauf der Mannschaft und sowas. Aber das Ereignis an sich liegt ja offen da und das kann jeder nachverfolgen. Und das Ereignis an sich durchläuft ja auch immer so Phasen. Und das war ja ganz spannend, weil 54 ja nun mal wirklich lange her ist und das ja auch ein Thema ist, wo die Protagonisten mittlerweile gestorben sind und wo aber auch die Leute, die es rezipiert haben, mittlerweile größtenteils entweder tot sind oder sie sind gerade dabei zu sterben. Es tut mir leid, das so brutal zu sagen. Weil natürlich auch die Rezeptionsgeschichte dann immer wieder Phasen durchläuft. Es gab Phasen, in denen waren die 54er Weltmeister total abgemeldet, da hat sich keiner dafür interessiert. Und dann irgendwann, gerade im Zuge der Wiedervereinigung, kam das dann wieder, so diese Erinnerung, weil man dann auch ja noch diese positiven Momente deutscher Geschichte gesucht hat und dann darin gefunden hat. Und das muss man natürlich alles aufgreifen. Man muss dann aufpassen, wie du es gerade schon gesagt hast, dass man dann nicht eben in dieses Narrativ mit reingeht, was dann nämlich von späterer Hand reingeschrieben wurde, ein Ereignis damals. Man muss aber auch aufpassen, dass man nicht nur dagegen anschreibt, weil man kann ja dann natürlich auch dann immer versuchen, die großartige Gegenposition zu beziehen und alles zu entmystifizieren und zu sagen, das war alles gar nicht so, guck mal hier. Dann hat man aber natürlich auch, finde ich, so nur mit einem Auge draufgeblickt. Im Idealfall versucht man es von mehreren Blickwinkeln auszusehen und dann auch die Rezeptionsbeschichte. In so einem Fall kann man ja auch, dann habe ich aufhören zu meinem Buch dann, dadurch dass es eben nicht mit 54 endet, sondern die Lebensgeschichte der Akteure noch bis zu ihrem Tod weiter erzählt, dass man ja auch dann die Rezeptionsgeschichte noch aufgreifen kann.
Also bei dem Buch 2006 war das gerade der Reiz, dieses Narrativ zu untersuchen und wie Tobi gesagt hat, richtig da neutral ranzugehen. War das Leben damals wirklich besser? War das Leben damals leichter? War die Gesellschaft damals weniger polarisiert? War die Welt, lebte mehr im Einklang miteinander mit der Idee, man kommt nur zusammen weiter? Das war der Reiz, dass ich mich, weil diese Erinnerung, dieses Narrativ hatte ich auch selber natürlich im Kopf und bin da rangegangen und habe versucht tatsächlich neutral ranzugehen. Wie war es denn wirklich, diese banale Frage mir zu stellen? Bei 1954, was Tobi untersucht hat, finde ich es ja ganz interessant, dass dieses veränderte Narrativ, also dass dieser Sieg immer größer wurde für die Bedeutung von Deutschland, für das deutsche Nationalgefühl auch. Das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass es einfach immer mehr Medien gab und dass diese Medien immer mehr Zeit hatten, immer mehr Platz hatten, Dinge zu untersuchen. Also, was Tobi zum Beispiel 1954 wirklich in den Zeitungen über dieses Ereignis gefunden hat. Ich habe das mal für einen Aufsatz untersucht und ich habe da überhaupt kaum Berichte darüber gefunden. Nicht, weil die Leute jetzt per se kein Interesse hatten oder weil es nicht so groß war. Sport war noch nicht so groß, aber auch einfach, weil es keinen Platz gab. Also, die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung 1954 hatte, glaube ich, aus dem Kopf würde ich sagen, acht oder zwölf Seiten und der Sport war teilweise eine halbe Seite. Und zwei Tage nach diesem Endspiel, das Wunder vom Bern, was damals übrigens niemand so nannte, war in der FAZ kein Bericht darüber, sondern nur Presse-Stimmen aus dem Ausland, was, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen was über die Zeit sagt. Also, es war in den Deutschen nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg sehr wichtig. Was denkt das Ausland über uns? Aber es war für die FAZ offenbar immer noch nur Sport und man hatte halt keinen Platz. Man hat halt nur diese halbe Seite und dann wurde das gar nicht mal zwei Tage später nicht mehr analysiert, dieses Ereignis.
Und der Wert von Sport hat sich auch sehr stark verändert, muss man dazu sagen. Also, wenn man dann in der Zeit, ich habe relativ viel dann geguckt, da findest du in der Regionalzeitung relativ viel, gerade in Süddeutschland. Weil ja nach der WM der Erfolgszug damals mit den Spielern, der ist ja einmal durch ganz Süddeutschland, von der Schweiz, durch Baden-Württemberg bis nach München gefahren. Und da hat es halt an jeder Station dann einen riesigen Auflauf gegeben. Und das war dann schon in diesen Lokalzeitungen sehr, sehr stark präsent. Und das war dann auch Titelseitenmaterial. Aber in den überregionalen Zeitungen, da gab es ja auch ganz wenig Sport. Also Sport war da teilweise in der Süddeutschen oder in solchen Zeitungen war eine halbe Seite maximal. Oder wenn es eine ganze Seite war, war dann aber auch viel anderer Sport. Also Fußball war ja dann nicht in der Form. Natürlich war es ein super populärer Sport, aber nicht dieser alles übergreifende Sport, das wenn du heute die Süddeutsche aufzeigst, sind von vier Seiten Sport, drei Seiten Fußball. Das war ja damals auch nicht. Dieser Wunderbegriff übrigens, den gab es damals schon, aber der war damals noch nicht so auf Bern gemünzt. Das war damals der Wundersommer, weil ich glaube, kurz nach dem Sieg von Bern gab es dann auch noch einen deutschen Sieg in Silverstone, im Autorennen fahren mit Mercedes. Das war dann auch noch ein Wunderereignis. Den Wunderbegriff gab es schon mit dem Wunder von Bern. Das kam natürlich später dann dazu. Aber ja, Fußball war damals nicht in dem Maße präsent, wie er heute präsent ist.
Und was war denn bei deinen Recherchen? Weil bei meinen, wie gesagt, oberflächlichen Recherchen über 1954 hatte ich auch den Eindruck, diese überhöhte Bedeutung, dass also die Wiedergeburt Deutschlands an diesem Tag stattfand, die Wiederauferstehung Deutschland, dass das damals auch noch kein Thema war, dass das auch ein Begriff erst war oder eine Einordnung, die vielleicht 30 Jahre später erst über dieses Ereignis gemünzt wurde. Was hast du dazu gefunden?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Das gab ja auch damals große Diskussionen. Da gab es ja dann die berühmte Bierkellerrede des DFB-Präsidenten, der dann da mit Rhetorik aufgewartet hat, die halt an die Rhetorik der Nationalsozialisten erinnert hat. Das hat dann tatsächlich viel größere Wellen geschlagen in der Zeit. Und das war, glaube ich, der Süddeutschen auch einen längeren Artikel wert, diese Rede auseinanderzunehmen. Und da hat auch der Bundespräsident dann den schönen Satz gesagt, guter Fußball ist noch keine gute Politik. Und das war dann eher so die Thematik. Und das kam dann erst später. Also, wie gesagt, ein meiner Lieblingsdetails aus diesem Buch ist tatsächlich Ottmar Walter, dass der Anfang der 80er, sein größter öffentlicher Auftritt damals war, vor einer Schulklasse in der Nähe von Cuxhaven aus Berlin, die sich alle gefragt haben, wer ist denn der Typ da vorne? Was soll der denn jetzt erzählen? Der Paul Breitner? Und dann meinte er jemanden, der Paul Breitner verliert sich doch nicht hier im Nest in Cuxhaven. Und zehn Jahre später wurde halt Ottmar Walter mit dem Bundesverdienstkreuz geehrt. Da gab es dann Ehrung und Ehrung um Ehrung und wirklich mit den höchsten Weinen. Und zum 80. Geburtstag war dann Kurt Beck dabei und und so weiter und so fort, weil halt in den 90er Jahren dieses 54 Ereignis sowas von wiederentdeckt wurde mit 50 Jahre 1954 mit der Wiedervereinigung. Da wurden diese Spieler dann plötzlich alle wiederentdeckt, die ebenso in der die verschwunden waren. Und manche Spieler fanden das ja auch gar nicht gut. Hans Schäfer war bis zum Ende seines Lebens, hat er gemurrt. So von wegen, jahrelang wollte er nichts von uns wissen. Und jetzt werden wir hier herumgereicht, wie die wie die Präsentierteller. Das hat schon auch für Unmut gesorgt.
Was wahrscheinlich daran lag, dass einfach die Bedeutung vom Fußball ab Mitte der 90er Jahre enorm angestiegen ist, also gesellschaftliche Bedeutung. Das ging ja einher damit, dass das Privatfernsehen Fußball so gezeigt hat als Ereignis, als Seifenoper, dass es also auch jetzt Leute schauen konnten, die sich gar nicht für Fußball interessieren, weil sie plötzlich David Beckham frontal im Groß gesehen haben oder plötzlich das Spiel wie ein Drama erzählt wurde mit persönlichen Duellen und so was. Und da wurde Fußball an sich größer. Und da hat man natürlich dann auch auf die 54er Weltmeister plötzlich wieder zurückgeguckt. Und die wurden auch größer dann erst mit diesem Abstand. Ich glaube, dass was interessant daran vielleicht auch ist, dass das oft tatsächlich auch mit, also dass es gar nicht systematisch oder nur zum Teil systematisch passiert. Das System dahinter war, das Privatfernsehen macht Fußball groß, weil es etwas zum Geldverdienen braucht. Aber neben dem Systematischen hat es immer auch eine persönliche Ebene. Und da erleben wir in der Mitte der 80er und der 90er Jahren, dass wir zum ersten Mal zwei Bundeskanzler haben, die Fußballfanatiker sind, Helmut Kohl und Gerhard Schröder, die beide auf ihre Art deswegen Fußball, zum einen aus Liebhaberei, zum anderen aus politischer Strategie, pushen. Also die zum ersten Mal die Nationalhymne gesungen hat eine bundesdeutsche Nationalmannschaft 1984 im Oktober gegen Schweden. Und das war in Absprache zwischen Helmut Kohl und dem damaligen DFB-Präsident Neuberger, weil man wieder vorsichtig das Nationale in den Vordergrund rücken wollte. Vorsichtig damals, da haben wir einen politischen Einfluss. Und dann hin zur WM 2006, diese Idee, sich um die WM zu bewerben, hat Gerhard Schröder sofort aufgegriffen und hat darin tatsächlich eine Chance gesehen, Deutschland, der Welt als offenes, als liebenswürdiges, aber auch als wirtschaftlich starkes Land zu präsentieren. Und so ist ja die WM 2006 gefördert worden, von staatlicher Seite, wie noch keine WM zuvor. Also deswegen ist glaube ich dieses ganze Größerwerden der 54er-Weltmeister tatsächlich einzuordnen in ein Größerwerden des Fußballs überhaupt in Deutschland.
Ich glaube, da kennst du dich jetzt auch viel besser aus. Aber die WM 74 und 2006 sind ja auch sehr kontrastreich, wenn du bedenkst, wie sie in Deutschland stattgefunden haben. Wenn ich mit meinen Eltern rede, die oder auch mit meinen Verwandten, die Fußballinteressiert sind, wie habt ihr damals die WM 74 erlebt? Na, da war halt eine WM im eigenen Land. Das hat damals nicht so in dem Maße gejuckt, wohingegen ich halt sehr konkret Erinnerung habe, 2006 Public Viewing mit Freunden und so weiter. Das war ein riesengroßes Ereignis auch in das ganz Deutschland berührt hat. Da kannst du ja auch nochmal anhand diesen beiden Weltmeisterschaften ganz gut erkennen, wie sich eben die Bedeutung des Fußballs gewandelt hat.
Ja, wobei 74 schon ein Sonderfall war dadurch, dass die Olympischen Spiele 1972 sollten ja ähnlich genutzt werden, politisch-gesellschaftlich wie die WM 2006. Zum ersten Mal war ein großes Sporteigens in Deutschland und man wollte sich fast 30 Jahre nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zeigen, als ein wieder in die Weltgemeinschaft eingeordnetes, liebenswertes Land. Und schon allein durch die Architektur des Olympiaparks, dass da das Olympiastadions mit einem Park drum herum, wo Gaukler sein sollten. Das alles wurde ja zerstört durch das Attentat der palästinensischen Terroristen auf die israelische Olympiamannschaft. Und deswegen war 1974, zwei Jahre danach, so ein Sonderfall. Da ging es wirklich für die Bundesrepublik nur darum, wir müssen dieses Turnier über die Bühne bringen, ohne dass etwas passiert. Man hatte auch das Gefühl, wir können jetzt nicht zwei Jahre wieder versuchen, dieses Turnier gesellschaftlich aufzublasen, sagen wir mal. Und deswegen war es tatsächlich im reinsten Sinne ein Sportereignis. Die meisten Leute haben es so erlebt wie deine Eltern. Ja, da waren ja WM im Land und da hat man vielleicht mal in den Sportteil geguckt. Die FAZ hat sich wortwörtlich bei ihren Lesern entschuldigt, dass sie etwas mehr über Fußball berichtet als sonst. Nämlich zwei Seiten seit einer Seite. Und zum Spiel Bulgarien gegen Uruguay in Hannover kamen 12.000 Zuschauer. Warum sollte man denn Bulgarien gegen Uruguay schauen? Und 2006 war in der Tat jeder wollte irgendwie dabei sein. Und wenn es beim Spiel war Serbien gegen Elfenbeinküste, wo es schon gar nichts mehr drum ging, weil beide Mannschaften schon ausgeschieden waren. Also es war tatsächlich ein Ereignis geworden, was natürlich auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat, dass wir vielmehr 2006 in so einer Art Eventkultur gelebt haben. Also auch ein Papstbesuch wurde und wird zum Event. Gab es glaube ich sogar 2006. Der Herr Ratzinger damals, der Deutsche Papst, kam nach Regensburg, meine ich. Und da wollten auch Leute dabei sein, die vielleicht sich gar nicht so sicher waren, ob sie an Gott glauben. Also wir haben schon viel mehr in diesem Event-Zeitalter gelebt.
Ja, es ist ja auch so ein soziologischer Ansatz, genau diese Zeit nach Ende des Kalten Krieges, was stößt dann in das Vakuum, wirtschaftlich relativ einfach zu erklären. Aber was macht das mit der Gesellschaft, ist einer der Ansätze eben zu sagen, dass es eben eher um Konsum und um Events ging, weil eben der Konsum irgendwann befriedigt war und dann Events die neue Art zu konsumieren waren. Kann man allerdings auch trefflich darüber streiten. Was ich allerdings interessant finde, ist, also in der Nebenbemerkung von Tobi kam ich gerade auf den Gedanken. Tobi hat gesagt, ja 1990 zur Wiedervereinigung, da hat man auch nach Momenten gesucht, die vereinigt sein könnten. Und das verweist ja schon mal auf eine vielleicht Problematik, aber zumindest eine Thematik, die wir haben, wenn wir über historische Sportereignisse in der Rückschau sprechen. Als Nationen versammelt man sich hinter Geschichten, denn Akfemeer hat man nicht. Also man hat so einen sozio-kulturellen Rahmen, Sprache, gewisse Eigenschaften und eben ein direktes soziales Nahfeld und Umfeld. Und dann, wenn man sich aber als Nation begreifen soll, dann ist das ja sehr, sehr abstrakt und vereinfacht gesagt. Also sehr überspitzt gesagt könnte man jetzt ja auch mit der These reinstarten. Naja, die deutsche Nation hatte zum Glück keine Kriege mehr, hinter denen man sich vereinigen konnte, die so nationale Erinnerungen sein konnten. Deswegen hat man sich im Sport seine Erinnerungen gesucht. Gleichzeitig kommen wir da aber dann ja auch in ein Thema rein, das man auch kritisch sehen kann. Ronny, du musstest das ja auch. Was heißt das? Du musstest. Du hast das ja auch in der Deutsche Sommer beschrieben. Ist das einfach nur positiv zu sehen, wenn es dann überall die Deutschland-Fahnen gibt, wenn sogar Flo Weber von den Sportfreunden Stiller die Deutschland-Fahne neben die Argentinien-Fahne hängt. Du hast das sehr schön beschrieben. Also wie gehst du denn mit diesem Zusammenhang um, dass wir auf der einen Seite durchaus Geschichten brauchen, an die wir uns alle ähnlich erinnern, denn das gibt einem eine kollektive Identität. Und gleichzeitig wissen wir aber natürlich auch, Nationalismus ist nicht immer die beste Idee für das Zusammenleben in einer Welt. Sehen wir ja gerade jetzt.
Also als Autor, denke ich, musst du erst mal damit so umgehen, dass du deine eigene Meinung nicht ins Buch einbringst, sondern dass du die Leute erzählen lässt und es vielleicht analysierst. Grundsätzlich finde ich, ist das, du hast es überspitzt genommen, ist das schon richtig. Also Gott sei Dank befasst sich die Mehrheit der Menschheit heute lieber mit Fußball spielen als mit Kriegen. Und Gott sei Dank ist die Kriegslust überall in der Gesellschaft sehr, sehr gering aufgrund all der schrecklichen Erfahrungen. Also wenn jemand dann sagt Fußball ist Kriegsersatz, dann ist es ein guter Ersatz. Und in den meisten Fällen ist es für die Leute dann auch nur ein Fußballspiel. Also gerade bei Ländern, die Fanatiker, die das als Deutschland Sieg betrachten, die sind ja durchaus sehr gering. Ich finde, man konnte den Unterschied auch sehr gut sehen bei der Europameisterschaft 2024 als Länder wie Albanien, auch Türkei und Serbien, wo diese diese Fußballspiele noch deutlich nationalistischer aufgeheizt waren. Also da ging es offenbar für viel mehr Leute tatsächlich noch darum, sich als Nation, das ist ja Nationalismus, über die anderen zu stellen, andere zu besiegen. Ich glaube, dass aber in den allermeisten Fußballländern, ob das jetzt Spanien ist, ob das Italien ist, ob das Deutschland ist, England, dass dann doch eher eine patriotische Übung ist. Also dass man da zusammenkommt, dass es da auch noch was gibt, wo man sich mit seinem Land identifiziert, wenn Deutschland spielt, aber dass es nicht mehr darum geht, unbedingt den anderen zu beziehen, sich als Nation besser zu fühlen als der andere, sondern im besten Sinne patriotisch, dass man sein Land mag, aber dass das Ganze auch nicht so wichtig mehr ist. Dass das eigentlich im Fußball mittlerweile im Vordergrund steht und dass man im Fußball durchaus auch eine gewisse Gelassenheit erkennen kann in Deutschland. Ja, war schade, dass Deutschland gegen Spanien nicht gewonnen hat 2024, aber die Leute regen sich dann doch eher künstlich auf über das Handspiel oder das Nicht-Handspiel. Also solche Aufreger als jetzt darüber, dass Deutschland nicht Europameister geworden ist und dadurch nicht besser ist als die anderen Nationen.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das Kukurelia genauso sehen würde, der noch Jahre später in deutschen Stadien bei irgendwelchen Clubwettbewerben ausgepfiffen wird. Gleichzeitig könnte man ja aber...
Ja, das sehe ich, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Harm. Also es ist schon ein bisschen so etwas über sich andere lustig machen, was im deutschen Humor offenbar nicht so ganz rauszukriegen ist. Das Humor ist, sich über andere lustig zu machen. Es ist auf, dass viele Leute auch zum Fußball gehen, bewusst, um sich aufzuregen. Aber es ist doch eher ein harmloser Ausdruck, finde ich jetzt. Darin sehe ich keinen nationalistischen Ausdruck. Ich würde sagen, als ich Kind war in den 80er Jahren, hätte sowas dazu geführt, dass viele Leute derb über die Spanier hergezogen hätten, mit irgendwelchen Klischees, dass die immer nur mit Glück gewinnen oder Betrug oder sonst was. Und das fand ja zumindest die Leute, die ich höre, jetzt nicht mehr statt. Also da wird das auch eventisiert, würde ich sagen. Auch das Aufregen wird eventisiert.
Ja, interessanter Punkt, wenn man sich mal mit dem Fußball in den 80ern beschäftigt und einfach nur von den unzähligen Morddrohungen liest, die da gegen Fußballspieler oder Funktionäre ausgesprochen wurden, wie oft die auch mit Polizeischutz zum Beispiel vom Flughafen abgeholt wurden und ins Hotel gebracht wurden. Also nicht als Eskorte, sondern tatsächlich, um sie zu schützen. Dann sieht man, dass sich da wirklich einiges verschoben hat. Aber gleichzeitig ist natürlich aber auch die Frage zu stellen, ob man da gerade so einen Rückschritt vielleicht auch erlebt. Ich weiß nicht, Tobi, ob du dazu eine Meinung hast, denn indirekt befassen wir uns mit diesen Themen immer wieder. Wir konzentrieren uns, wir zwei, halt immer so aufs analytische und aufs Verkopfte. Aber zum Beispiel WM jetzt 26. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie ich sie im Rasenfunk stattfinden lassen möchte. Ich erlebe aber jetzt schon an vielen Ecken, zum Teil auch in meinem sozialen Umfeld, dass Menschen zum Beispiel sich wünschen, die USA scheiden früh aus, denn gerade weil auch alles gerade aufgeladen wird von den USA, wünscht man ihnen diese sportliche Niederlage, denn sie haben es auch politisch und so weiter verdient. Also ich erlebe da schon gerade wieder eine Verschärfung und vielleicht einen, ich würde es dann schon, einen Rückschritt nennen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Rückschritt ist. Es ist auch wieder so ein Zeitgeistthema. Ronny hat das ja auch schon so ein bisschen beschrieben, dass gerade erleben wir so ein bisschen die Politisierung von allem, würde ich behaupten. Also man versucht, in alles politische Dinge rein zu interpretieren. Und dann ist natürlich so eine WM da ganz vorne mit dabei. Das gab es in diesem Maße ja bei anderen Turnieren nicht. Also gerade 1954 war man ja damals eben mit einer ganz anderen Geschichte damals sehr, sehr bemüht, dieses Ereignis komplett zu entpolitisieren. Und das ist ja, wie gesagt, ich habe ja vorhin den Spruch gesagt, gut, der Fußball ist noch keine gute Politik. Wir sind jetzt halt in einem anderen Zeitalter, was natürlich auch mit vielen, was auch viele inhaltliche Gründe hat. Wenn du dir anschaust, wie die FIFA eben Turniere vergibt und wie die FIFA auch unter Gianni Infantino aktuell funktioniert und sich an den US-Präsidenten herangeschmissen hat, dass diese Themen dann natürlich größer sind. Man muss aber natürlich auch sagen, dass Fußball eine größere Bedeutung hat als selbst noch vor 20 Jahren heute. Weil nun, ich bin immer auch nicht sicher, diese Zersplitterung der Gesellschaft, wie man diese These betrachten soll. Aber es ist ja so, dass es nur noch wenige Ereignisse gibt, die wirklich einen Großteil der deutschen Bevölkerung erreichen. Ich habe jetzt gesehen, zum Beispiel die neue Stefan Rapschow hat 1,5 Millionen Zuschauer im Fernsehen. Und das wurde dann als Erfolg gefeiert. Das wäre früher halt das Nachtprogramm gewesen in der ARD, wo die Leute eingeschlafen sind und dann den Rauschbildschirm. Und deshalb wahrscheinlich 1,5 Millionen früher erreicht. Deutschland schönste Bahnstrecken. Rest in peace. Ja, du guckst, die Wahl in Rheinland-Pfalz und die Hälfte der Wahlberechtigten wissen nicht, wer die beiden Kandidaten sind, die auf dem Wahlburg realistische Chancen haben, Ministerpräsident zu werden. Wohingegen, wenn du dir anguckst, welche Menschen haben in Deutschland noch, erreichen noch 90 Prozent und drüber an Bekanntheitsgraden. Das sind größtenteils Menschen aus dem Fußballkosmos. Natürlich sind dann diese Ereignisse werden dann nochmal durch viele andere Dinge aufgeladen, weil das einfach eine der wenigen Ereignisse sind, wo alle wirklich, ich will nicht sagen, zusammenkommen, wo alle ein Interesse haben, wo auch alle eine Meinung zu haben können und auch haben.
Ja, die zehn meistgeschautesten Fernsehsendungen sind allesamt Fußballspiele. Also das spricht schon dafür, dass der Fußball zumindest in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren schon immer größer war als alles andere. Und das aufgrund der Vielfalt der Möglichkeiten, was die Leute heute machen können, wie sie ihre Zeit verbringen können, welche Medien sie konsumieren, hast du sonst kaum noch Ereignisse. Selbst, Tobias hat es gesagt, selbst Wahlen nicht mehr, die sozusagen alle angehen. Also die Wahlbeteiligung ist ja auch in den, ich glaube, bei 1974 oder 1972 war das, da lag sie dann bei irgendwie über 92 Prozent, die Wahlbeteiligung. Das waren tatsächlich noch Ereignisse, weil aber auch, muss man sagen, nicht, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es für die Menschen eine höhere Bedeutung hatte oder weil einfach viel weniger los war damals. Also viel weniger, was man auch sonntag machen kann, platt gesagt. Und da ist Fußball durch diesen Spannungsmoment, dass man ihn eigentlich in dem Moment schauen muss, wenn man, also dieses Dabeisein ist noch viel wichtiger als bei anderen Sachen. Stefan Raab kann ich mir auch noch zehn Tage später um zwei Uhr nachts anschauen oder so was. Das kann ich beim Fußballspiel theoretisch auch, aber dann weiß ich halt schon, wie es ausgegangen ist. Und deswegen ist Fußball so ein Ereignis tatsächlich, was noch sehr, sehr viele Menschen beschäftigt. Und ja, ob es dann wirklich die Nation jemals zusammengebracht hat, vielleicht in den Köpfen in dem Moment schon sehr viele Leute wollten dann tatsächlich, dass die in dem Moment, wenn ein Länderspiel ist, dieselbe Mannschaft gewinnt, Deutschland gewinnt. Aber durch diese Politisierung, das wird ja auch auf die Fußballmannschaft übertragen. Der Streit darum, ob da jetzt farbige Deutsche zu viel spielen oder zu wenig spielen, sowas. Diese Diskussionen sind auch im Fußball angekommen. Und das ist, weil wir in einer Zeit leben, in der tatsächlich viel einschneidendere, große politische Ereignisse wir damit zurechtkommen müssen. Also, es ging ja los eigentlich mit der Covid-Pandemie, dann Russlands Angriff gegen die Ukraine, dann die erratische autoritäre Politik von Trump. Das sind Sachen, die ja tatsächlich alle spüren in ihrem eigenen Leben. Sei es darum, ob das Benzin teurer wird, sei es darum, dass ihre Aktien sinken, die sie gespart haben für ihren Alterssitz, sei es darum, dass die Leute sehen, ihre Kleinstadt verändert sich, weil wir mehr Einwanderer haben, mehr Immigranten haben. Deswegen wird das automatisch auch auf das größte Ereignis, das alle noch zusammenverfolgen, den Fußball übertragen. Aber ich glaube, dass wir diese Zersplitterung definitiv in der Gesellschaft, aber eine Polarisierung gehört zu einer Gesellschaft dazu. Wenn es die nicht gäbe, dann würden wir in einer Diktatur leben, wo eine Polarisierung unterdrückt werden würde. Und das war vielleicht sogar das Alleinstellungsmerkmal für 2006, dass durch die Politik von Angela Merkel und das Zusammengehen der SPD und CDU zu einer großen Koalition in diesem Moment eine Polarisierung kleiner denn je war und sich auch diese traditionelle Polarisierung in rechts CDU, links SPD aufgelöst hat. Da waren natürlich noch viele andere Faktoren, spielt da eine Rolle, also dass die Arbeiter- schaft, die Industriearbeiter- schaft kleiner wurde, immer mehr durch Veränderungen und sowas. Aber das war 2006 wahrscheinlich tatsächlich ein Punkt, der beim Feier der WM geholfen hat, dass also in diesem Moment historisch einmalig die Polarisierung in Deutschland relativ gering war.
Ja, man könnte daran auch viele Probleme sehen, die wir jetzt aktuell haben, aber auch deswegen erinnert man sich ja...
Natürlich hat sich dann wieder eine neue Polarisierung musste sich bilden und dadurch, dass CDU und SPD quasi nicht mehr zwei Pole waren, wurde an den Rändern rechts und links von ihnen wieder was frei für eine, es hat sich eine neue Opposition gebildet. Ja, und ob die jetzt sachlicher ist, wage ich mal zu bezweifeln.
Ja, ich meinte das ehrlicherweise sogar noch mehr auf ökonomische Zwänge bezogen. Also mir ist es aufgefallen, ich habe noch mal alle Bücher gelesen und es ist schon interessant, schon 1954 war es so, direkt nach dem Krieg, das es quasi Großindustrielle waren, die ersten, die wieder Geld hatten und die konnten dann eben auch Fußballvereine sich leisten, die mit Kartoffeln bezahlen und so weiter und so fort. Also schon damals war es quasi so, es gab eine wirtschaftliche Elite, die trotz den Schrecken des Zweiten Weltkrieges ökonomisch erfolgreich da rausgekommen sind. Und ähnlich hast du das eigentlich 2006. Es ist ja auch eine Wirtschaftsgeschichte der Sommer 2006. Du beschreibst es ja sehr schön, wie sich Deutschland da auch global positioniert hat als ein Land der Innovation, als ein Land auch mit Selbstironie, als ein Land, in dem man leicht nicht nur Fabriken bauen kann, sondern man kann sie dann eben auch zu einem Mindestlohn betreiben, beziehungsweise zu einem Niedriglohnsektor, der wurde damals aufgebaut. Die Hartz-IV-Reform haben unter anderem damals dorthin geführt. Konnte man alles 2006 noch nicht wissen, also zumindest noch nicht abschätzen, glaube ich, in der Art und Weise, wie es passiert ist. Aber ich finde das schon spannend, dass diese ökonomischen Zwänge, die, glaube ich, die größten unserer Zeit sind. Einige wenige sind überreich und viele haben eher Probleme, ihren Lebensunterhalt zu finanzieren, dass man die am Fußball halt besser beschreiben kann als an ganz, ganz vielen anderen. Oder bin ich da jetzt zu kritisch, Ronny?
Ob man es besser beschreiben kann, man kann es beschreiben, wenn man also den, den Fußball als Anlass nimmt zu einer gesellschaftlichen Analyse. Wenn man es jetzt nur rein ökonomisch beschreibt, ist es vielleicht für viele nicht so, nicht so leicht zu lesen, weil es dann doch langweilig wird, außer man ist der absolute Wirtschaftsnörder.
Deswegen sage ich ja, wir erzählen es anhand des Fußballs. Also ist es da...
Also das war die Idee des Buches, ja. Also tatsächlich ja die Gesellschaft. Wobei, wie gesagt, die andere Idee war ja auch eine rein fußballerische, mal zu schauen, wie wichtig waren die Anstöße, die Jürgen Klinsmann damals für den Fußball gegeben hat. Wie neu waren sie wirklich für den deutschen Fußball? Also es ist schon auch eine Fußballgeschichte.
Tobias, du hattest schon Luft geholt. Ich habe dich unterbrochen, Entschuldigung.
Nee, alles gut. Du hast mich gar nicht unterbrochen. Ich hatte jetzt zwei Anknüpfungspunkte. Das eine war das, was auch interessant ist, wenn man sich mit dem Fußball beschäftigt. Du hast im Fußball einen hohen Kulturpessimismus. Also im Fußball ist zu jeder Dekade der Fußball der letzten 20 Jahre der Beste gewesen. Also du hast immer die aktuelle Generation. Das war schon Fritz Walter war schon eigentlich zu weich für den Fußball und man bräuchte härtere Kerle und das zieht sich ja durch, dass die Deutschen nach einem Anführer auf dem Fußballplatz suchen, der vorangeht. Das ist eine Klage im deutschen Fußball, die so alt ist wie der deutsche Fußball selbst. Und genauso der Untergang des Fußballs wird uns ja auch seit 100 Jahren schon prophezeit, dass der Fußball, wenn er so weitermacht, eben nicht zukunftsfähig ist. Den Gedanken hatte ich gerade, als du mit dem Hyperkapitalismus kommst, weil das ist ja auch eine Entwicklung, die wir im Fußball haben, nämlich, dass die Reichen immer reicher werden und die Kluft immer größer wird. Gleichzeitig steigt die Beliebtheit des Fußballs immer weiter und die Leute scheinen damit gar kein riesengroßes Problem zu haben, dass Bayern München neun von zehn Mal Meister wird. Trotzdem sind die Einschaltquoten im Fußball, sie fallen nicht in der Bundesliga. Das ist ja eine interessante Entwicklung, die man da auch erlebt. Aber dieser Kulturpessimismus ist, wenn man das geschichtlich betrachtet, im Fußball sehr, sehr groß. Also es ist immer so, dass der Fußball, den man selbst zwischen zehn und zwanzig erlebt hat, war der beste Fußball, den es gab und so was. Und da kommt noch eine andere Komponente hinzu, die Ronny gerade genannt hat. Es gibt ja neben dem kulturell, politisch, sozioökonomischen Aspekt der Fußballgeschichte auch noch einen ganz eigenen, nämlich die sportliche Geschichte des Fußballs. Weil Fußball ist ja, Adam Pfirsich erst einmal in sich betrachtet, ein Spiel zu 11 gegen 11, das auf diesem Fußballplatz stattfindet, das natürlich auch eine ganz eigene Geschichte hat. Und natürlich eine Geschichte, wie wird dieses Fußballspiel gespielt? Wie haben sich die Regeln dieses Fußballspiels entwickelt? Wie haben sich wiederum diese Entwicklung der Regeln auf das, wie auf dem Fußballfeld gespielt wird, ausgewirkt? Wie hat sich die Körperlichkeit, wie hat sich die Körperkultur der Spieler entwickelt? Da sind ja noch viele Aspekte drin, die ja eine ganz eigene Geschichtsschreibung haben, eine ganz eigene sportgeschichtliche Bedeutung haben, die man ja auch immer wieder analysieren und drauf gucken kann. Die ja vor allen Dingen mich auch interessieren bei solchen Fragen. Wie hat sich der Fußball entwickelt zu dem, was er heute ist?
Also, weil du sagst, dieser kulturpessimistische Blick auf den auf den Fußball, das ist für mich schon ein sehr deutsches Phänomen. Ich lebe jetzt seit 30 Jahren im Ausland, England, Spanien, Italien. Und hier in diesen Ländern hatte ich das Gefühl, da gibt es auch Unterströmungen, die alles kritisch sehen. Aber das sind Leute, die grundsätzlich alles im Leben erst mal kritisch sehen. Also, in Deutschland ist man jetzt, das Spiel gibt es jetzt ungefähr 150 Jahre Fußball. Man ist immer noch nicht so weit, es wirklich als Geschäft zu akzeptieren. Das, glaube ich, kommt traditionell aus, weil Fußball in Deutschland ja aus dem Vereinswesen, aus dem Gemeinwesen heraus entstanden ist. Während es in anderen Ländern war, war Fußball immer schon ein Geschäft. Die erste englische Premier League, natürlich damals nicht, aber die erste englische Liga, die 1800, ungefähr 1880 gegründet wurde, das waren alles Unternehmen, diese Vereine, die sofort Geschäftsleute hatten. Und deswegen gibt es in Deutschland eine deutlich größere Skepsis gegenüber dem Geschäft Fußball. Und das verleitet natürlich zum Pessimismus, weil dieses Geschäft ja immer größer wird und immer mehr Gelder umsetzt. Sowas. Und das wirft viele Deutsche wieder in dieses Gefühl zurück. Wir verkaufen den Fußball. Ein anderer interessanter Punkt. Und wir können erst mal darüber reden, den anderen interessanten Punkt.
Ja, da würde ich gerne noch einsteigen, weil ich bei einem kleinen Punkt immer gerne widerspreche, weil wir immer das Vereinswesen sehr hoch halten. Aber wenn du natürlich anschaust, welche Vereine sind in Deutschland heute in der Bundesliga ganz vorne, das sind alles Vereine, das sind größtenteils Vereine, die kurz vor oder nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aus großen Städten als Repräsentationsvereine für diese großen Städte von Mizenen groß gemacht wurden und dann eben mit diesem, auch mit Hilfe von Mizenatentum, nach oben gekommen sind. Der 1. FC Köln ist da natürlich das Paradebeispiel als solch ein Verein. Aber auch viele andere Vereine sind eben da groß, weil sie aus großen Städten kommen, wo es viele Sponsoren gab, wo es auch dann damals halt viele Mizene gab, die eben sich um die Vereine gekümmert haben. Und das ist dann die Vereine, wo man wirklich sagen kann, dass sie groß geworden sind, obwohl sie eigentlich niedrigen Bedingungen trotzen mussten. Da gibt es den 1. FC Kaiserslautern noch, der eigentlich nicht da sein sollte, ökonomisch. Aber ansonsten ist das schon eine sehr ökonomische Auswahl an Vereinen. Und dieses traditionshafte, was wir bei Geld kritisch sehen, das kommt eher aus diesem Amateurgedanken, der am Deutschen, dieser edle Amateur, der am Deutschen immer hochgehalten wurde, der nicht fürs Geld spielt, sondern der für diesen Spaß an der Sache spielt. Das ist ja auch eine sehr, sehr deutsche Konstruktion, noch viel stärker als im Ausland, die ja dafür gesorgt hat, dass im Deutschland eben Bezahlung für Fußballspieler sehr lange, sehr weit hinter dem Ausland zurückhing, weil eben dort Fußball, du spielst es ja, weil du Spaß haben willst und du spielst es, weil du ein Edel-Amateur bist und nicht, weil du Geld haben möchtest. Ich glaube, dieser Gedanke ist sehr stark im Deutschen verwurzelt, wo es ja auch immer sehr anrüchig ist, wenn ein Spieler für einen höher dotierten Vertrag von A nach B wechselt. So, sportliche Perspektive ist immer ein Argument, weswegen Spieler wechseln darf, aber weil er das zehnmal verdient, das ist kein Argument. Deswegen darf ein Spieler nicht wechseln.
Deswegen glaube ich auch, was du gesagt hast, dass dieses Mezenatentum nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg von den Leuten verdrängt wird. Also die Illusion wird aufrechterhalten, teilweise sehr verkrampft in Deutschland, dass das doch mein Verein ist und man sich dort auch engagieren sollte. Das bringt ja auch sehr viele gute Sachen hervor, dieser soziale Gedanke eines Vereins. Aber man sieht ja auch, wie das verkrampft versucht wurde, zu verdrängen, dass man erst mal einen Profifußball dann eingeführt hat, 1963, dann sollte es aber dann doch keinen richtigen Gehälter geben, sondern dann wurde eine Gehaltsobergrenze festgezogen, wo jedem schon klar war, die kann nicht eingehalten werden. Und das schwingt immer noch in Deutschland so mit. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist dieser Kulturpessimismus, zumindest in Deutschland, ein deutlich größeres Phänomen als jetzt in Spanien, Italien oder England. Der andere Gedanke, der mir kam, als du sagst, das fand ich interessant, also das Bild, dass wir Deutschen von unserem Fußball haben. Und da hast du gesagt, schon Fritz Walter war den Leuten 1954 zu weich. Das fand ich jetzt interessant, weil ich hätte gedacht, dieses Bild, das wir von uns selber haben, von unserem Fußball, der also immer mit Kampf gewinnt, der mit Willen gewinnt, dass das von 1954 herhören würde. Also ich hätte gedacht, dass wir sozusagen 1954, der große Außenseiter-Sieg gegen Ungarn, kann doch nur so erklärt werden, dass wir einen größeren Willen hatten. Dass wir mehr gekämpft haben, dass wir mehr Team waren, dass wir Leidenschaftlicher haben. Und dass da die Mehr- oder das Selbstbild des Deutschen vom deutschen Tugenden, tragenden Fußballer begann. Würdest du da widersprechen? Also dass dieses Bild eigentlich schon vorher da war?
Nein, ich würde nicht widersprechen. Es hat sich auf jeden Fall gefestigt. Also natürlich ist die Blaupause des deutschen Fußballs. Wir wollen es mehr. Wir können bis zum Schluss kämpfen. Wir geben nie auf. Und das führt zu Erfolgen. Ich glaube, was neu war mit 54 war, das führt zu Erfolgen, weil der deutsche Fußball war ja bis 1954 nicht erfolgreich. Er galt nicht als Weltspitze, sondern wir galten als Fußballentwicklungsland zu jener Zeit. Und der große Fußball wurde ja woanders gespielt. Der wurde in den Donauländern gespielt und in den Südamerika und vor allen Dingen in den britischen Ländern. Und dass man damit Erfolg haben kann, war das Neue. Und deswegen, diese Figur Fritz Walter ist am ehesten zu vergleichen mit der Figur Bastian Schweinsteiger, dem ja heute auch so ein, durch die WM 2014, so ein Kampfschwein Attitüde nachhängt, die er ja gar nicht hatte. Also Bastian Schweinsteiger, erinnern wir uns ja noch daran, in der zeitgenössischen Medienberichterstattung galt immer als ein Spieler, der nicht genug kämpfen wollte, der nicht genug galt, dem eben dieses letzte Stückchen gefehlt hat. Diese Generation Lahm, Schweinsteiger, die galten ja auch als die unerfüllte Generation, weil denen eben dieser Anführer gefehlt hat. Das war ja mal so ein bisschen das Narrativ, das man bis 2014 hochgehalten hat und dann durch das Finale hat sich das erst gewandelt. Und so ist es ja auch Fritz Walter ergangen, weil Fritz Walter galt wirklich als, war ja auch ein zaudernder Mann, einer, der vor jedem Spiel auf dem Klo verschwunden ist mit Bauchschmerzen, weil er eben diese Nervosität nicht aushalten konnte, aber der eben mit solchen fußballerischen Fähigkeiten gesegnet war, dass er eine Mannschaft mitreißen konnte. Und der dann aber bei der WM 1954 eben in diese Rolle des Kampfschweins dann mit reingeraten ist, wie die ganze Mannschaft, was ihn so ein bisschen dann in der Wahrnehmung verändert hat. Und was auch dann diese deutsche Wahrnehmung des Fußballs geschaffen hat. Wenn man dann gesagt hat, das ist die Blaupause, wie wir halt eine Fußballnation mit Erfolg sein können. Und diese Blaupause gilt ja bis heute, wo es ja, bis heute kannst du ja ohne Kampf kein Fußballspiel gewinnen in Deutschland.
Ja, jetzt wieder nicht. Wurde ja von Matthias Sammer wieder angemahnt, dass uns die Kampfkraft fehlt. Aber das sind tolle Beispiele, wie wir für unsere Erinnerung auch einfache Wahrheiten brauchen. Also, Sebastian Schnurrheinsteigers Bild wurde auf den Kopf gestellt durch ein einziges Bild, wie er am Boden liegt und blutet und getackert wird und wieder aufsteht und weiter spielt noch die drei Minuten im WM-Finale gegen Argentinien. Und das Bild von Fritz Walter als Kampfsau, den würde ich zum Beispiel widersprechen aus den zehn Szenen, die aus dem WM-Finale überliefert sind, die es noch gibt, filmisch vom WM-Finale 1954. Da sieht man ihn als ein Mann, der ganz tolle Pässe spielt, der auch den Doppelpass sucht, der geniale Ideen hat. Aber damals hat ja kaum jemand das Spiel gesehen. Und da, glaube ich, reicht dann einfach auch der Fakt, man hat 3 zu 2 gegen Ungarn nach Rückstand, nach 2 zu 0 Rückstand gewonnen noch. Das reichte, dass man dieses Spiel umgebogen hat. Also da muss eine hohe Kampfkraft in dem Spiel gewesen sein. Übrigens Fritz Walter, nur am Rande, wenn wir über unsere Bücher sprechen, können wir vielleicht mal Werbung machen, auch für ein anderes Buch, aber für ein ganz tolles Buch. Fritz Walter, 3 zu 2, das Spiel ist aus. Deutschland ist Weltmeister, wo er darüber schreibt, über seine Zeit in der Schweiz, wo genau dieses Zaudern, dieses Charakters, dieses Angst haben, sich selber in Frage stellen, ganz toll herauskommt.
Fritz Walter ist, was Buchschreiben angeht, sehr interessant, weil er hat irgendwie sechs oder sieben Bücher geschrieben und er schafft das dann natürlich auch, sich zeitweise selbst zu widersprechen im Verlaufe dieser Bücher. Das Franz-Beckenbauer-Problem. Das Franz-Beckenbauer-Problem ein Stück weit. Genau, ja, Punkt.
Ja, weil Bücher machen anders als heute. Wir machen das natürlich nur aus ideellen Gründen. Aber damals war es der beste Weg, sich zu vermarkten, damals als Fußballer. Also was hat man gemacht, wenn man Erfolg hatte? Man hat ein Buch geschrieben und die Leute haben es gekauft. Und damals, dass man über den Punkt funktionierte, die Erinnerung musste die Erinnerung auch anders funktionieren, weil es keine Bilder gab, mit der man sie füllen konnte. Also ich erinnere mich an ein Gespräch mit Bernd Hölzenbein, dem 74er Weltmeister, wo er mir schilderte, wie oft er in einem Fritz-Walter-Buch ein Foto angeschaut hat. Nach dem Foto, das war, glaube ich, ein berühmtes Tor von Fritz Walter, was er mit der Hacke geschossen hat. Und er liegt in der Luft. Und Bernd Hölzenbein hat sich diese komplette Szene ausgemalt. Also wie ist der Ball zu Fritz Walter gekommen? Wie kam es, dass er in der Luft lieg, oder sowas? Also da ist in der Fantasie die Erinnerung gebildet worden, weil es kein Material gab, um sie zu füttern.
Ja, da gibt es viele dieser Geschichten. Das war das Spiel. Erster FC Kerserslautern gegen Wismut Karl-Marx-Stadt damals, glaube ich. Deutscher Meister gegen DDR-Meister in Leipzig vor einem vollen Stadion, wo er eben mit der Hacke das Tor erzielt hat, was dann auch nur auf Bildern eben, also auf Foto-Bildern beliefert wurde.
Aber da sind wir bei einem ganz interessanten Nebenthema, möchte ich fast schon sagen. Und zwar der erste Filter, den es gibt, wenn man ein Fußballbuch schreibt, ist ja, dass man etwas Visuelles in Sprache übersetzen muss. Und jetzt gibt es da so zwei Modi. Der eine Modus ist, wir erzählen den Leuten da draußen von Spielszenen, die sie sehr wahrscheinlich nicht in Erinnerung haben. Es gibt natürlich dann immer die drei Leute, die einem Leserbrief schreiben, die damals im Stadion waren und sich anders erinnern. Aber wir schreiben über unbekannte Szenen und den aber noch, finde ich, schwierigeren Fall. Wir reden über Szenen, bei denen zumindest Fußballfans Bilder im Kopf haben. Also sprich, ich beschreibe das Tor von Mario Götze im WM-Finale 2014 oder ich beschreibe, bei dir Ronny, ist mir das aufgefallen, 2006 dann das Tor von Oliver Neuville nach Flanke von Odonkor, die Initialzündung dieser WM oder Tobi natürlich bei dir. Bei dir kommt es ja sogar zweimal vor, einmal im Prolog und dann später nochmal. Natürlich, Ran müsste aus dem Hintergrund schießen. Er schießt Tor, Tor, Tor. Und Ronny, ich habe mich gefragt, wie du da rangehst, weil mir fällt immer wieder auf, dass du ganz anders über das Spiel Fußball schreibst, als ich es in vielen anderen Büchern lese. Auch, weil ich glaube, zu erkennen, dass du jeden bereits gesagten Satz, also berühmte Floskeln, schickte jemanden in die Tiefe oder sie versuchten den Doppelspass oder sie überluden die Seite. Sowas, also ich glaube, zu erkennen, dass du sowas wie der Teufel das Weihwasser meidest. Wie gehst du an das an das Zildern von Spielszenen heran, gerade von solchen, die ja alle eigentlich irgendwo in ihrem Hirn auch gespeichert haben?
Also, du hast richtig, hast recht. Ich meide die Fußballsprache, weil ich sie oft sehr bürokratisch finde. Und das ist tatsächlich auch ein bewusster Prozess gewesen, dass mir irgendwann gefragt habe, warum soll ich Worte benutzen, die Fußballtrainer in die Welt geschafft haben, die aber mit Sprache eigentlich schlechter umgehen können als ich. Also ich sehe das arrogant sozusagen als meine Hoheit, dass ich ja sprachlich eigentlich in dem Bereich bin ich besser als die Fußballtrainer. Die verstehen das Spiel viel besser als ich. Aber warum soll ich solche bürokratischen Worte übernehmen? Und deswegen versuche ich mit meinen eigenen Worten die Szenen so zu beschreiben. Ich glaube aber, ich fürchte, sie lösen bei den Lesern nicht unbedingt ein ganz neues Bild aus. Also ich glaube dann doch, wenn sich ein Leser dieses Tor von Odonkor auf Neuville, wenn er das schon im Kopf hat, dass dann bei ihm die alte Spule trotzdem abgeschwult wird. Also ich habe das als Beispiel mit unserem Sohn mal drüber geredet. Und da hat er gesagt, wenn er Romane liest und da wird ein Zimmer beschrieben, dann hat er immer unser Wohnzimmer im Kopf sofort, zieht er vor sich. Dann sag ich, wie? Ja, das geht automatisch. Wenn ein Zimmer beschrieben wird, egal wie in einem Roman, ist er automatisch in unserem Wohnzimmer. Also ich glaube, die Fähigkeit eines Schriftstellers oder Buchautoren, wirklich neue Bilder in die Köpfe der Menschen zu setzen, ist sehr begrenzt. Mir geht es zum Beispiel bei Romanfiguren so, ich habe relativ schnell im Roman, nach der ersten oder zweiten Beschreibung, den Menschen vor mir und ich glaube, ich ändere mein Bild da auch nicht, wenn er ganz anders beschrieben wird in einer fortlaufenden Geschichte. Also diese einmal fest gesetzten Bilder können wir schlecht ändern. Ich glaube aber, wenn wir beim Odonkor Tor bleiben, dass ich tatsächlich da den Leser noch etwas Neues geben konnte, weil ich dieses Tor mehrmals geschaut habe und den Anfang dieses Tors mir noch mal angeschaut habe und fand, das ist ja interessant. Also wir sehen, wie der polnische Torwart einen Freistoß aus dem eigenen Strafraum abschlägt. Das Spiel ist eigentlich vorbei. Es laufen die letzten Sekunden. Philipp Lahm gewinnt den Zweikampf an der Außenlinie. Und im Normalfall hätte er jetzt einen langen Ball nach vorne schlagen müssen, weil da steht Niro, das ist auf Klose, und der versucht halt irgendwie den Ball mit dem Kopf zu gewinnen, abzulegen. Vielleicht kommt ein anderer deutscher Spieler, der macht einen Tor. Und Philipp Lahm macht das Gegenteil. Er passt sicher zurück zu Mezelda. Und dann passen die fünf oder sechs Mal hin und her in der Abwehr. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist doch interessant. Das ist völlig atypisch. Und dann bin ich dem nachgegangen, habe mit Spielern drüber geredet und dann sagte mir Thomas Hitzelsberger was. Jogi Löw hat uns verboten, einen langen Pass zu spielen. Das war dessen Besessenheit. Und da glaube ich, gebe ich den Lesern nochmal etwas Neues mit, einen neuen Gedanken, dass die tatsächlich in den letzten Sekunden eines Spiels so gespielt haben, wie kaum eine andere Mannschaft es in dieser Situation getan hätte. Dass sie sich wirklich dran gehalten haben, ruhig hinten aufzubauen. Und dann plötzlich sieht Bernd Schneider den in die Tiefe startenden Odonkor und spielt diesen Chipball. Also da kann man vielleicht noch einen neuen Aspekt hinzufügen, aber die Bilder in den Köpfen der Leute nicht unbedingt ändern.
Ich werde mich jetzt der ganz unangenehmen Schleimerei verdächtig machen müssen, aber eine Frage, wie ein Autor wie Ronald Reng eine Szene schildert, das ist etwa so, wenn man Messi fragt, wie funktioniert ein Dribbling? Also wir iridischen Autoren, wir haben da andere Probleme. Wenn ich versuche, eine Szene zu schildere, versuche ich erst mal die Hauptworte zu finden. Und Schreiben ist ein Unf- Ich hasse Schreiben, sage ich immer wieder, ich hasse es, Bücher zu schreiben. Es ist eine Notwendigkeit, die entsteht, um diese Dinge von A nach B zu bekommen. Und der Prozess des Schreibens fällt mir unfassbar schwer. Ich möchte aber noch einmal anschließen, was du gesagt hast, Ronny, weil das, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist. Ich finde Szenen, die jeder kennt, super einfach zu schreiben. Weil du da nämlich überhaupt keine Bilder im Kopf von irgendjemanden auslösen musst. Also die Leute haben ja schon das Ogronkator im Kopf und die Leute haben ja schon das 54er Weltmeistertor. Das hat jeder deutsche Fußballfan, selbst wenn er sich nicht dafür interessiert, im Kopf. Da kann man sich, finde ich, dann wirklich, das hast du ja auch gerade schon gesagt, gut darauf konzentrieren, da Details rauszukratzen, die eben nur nicht jeder gesehen hat. Wo dann halt eben dann die Leute sagen, okay, das Detail ist mir noch gar nicht so aufgefallen. Ich habe das Ding tausendmal gesehen, aber hier, das Detail, das kann ich noch reingehen. Ganz schwierig, finde ich, Szenen zu beschreiben, wo ich weiß, die hat kein Mensch gesehen. So, es gibt eine unfassbar großartige Szene von Fritz Walther, wo er zweimal am Stück zwei Gegenspieler stehen lässt. Also er schafft es wirklich erst durch zwei Gegenspieler durch zu marschieren und dann rechts an zwei weiteren Gegenspieler vorbei zu marschieren. Dann setzt er die Flanke an den zweiten Pfosten, das fällt ein Tor. Um sowas zu beschreiben, fällt mir dann unfassbar viel schwerer, weil du hast da ein ganz komplexes, das Fußballspiel ist ja ganz komplex, wo steht welcher Spieler und so weiter und so fort. Das zu beschreiben, finde ich ganz komplex. Ich bin da leider zu sehr Bürokrat. Ich bin ja auch einer der wenigen, es gab in den 30er Jahren irgendwann mal einen Radiokommentator, der wollte einführen, dass jede Zone auf dem Feld einen Namen bekommt. Also die Eckenfahne links ist dann Zone A1, dann im Straferaum hast du irgendwie Zone A6. Und dann musste er nur noch sagen, Ball fliegt von A1 zur A6. Das finde ich persönlich als einer von fünf Menschen auf der ganzen Welt charmant. Aber da muss man schon ein sehr großer Bürokrat sein, um so was zu mögen. Da braucht man dann eben Sprache als Werkzeug.
Zu den anderen vier Menschen, die das charmant finden, gehört sicher Louis van Gaal, oder? Der würde sowas oft finden.
Ja, haben Sie interessanterweise... Teddy Wakelin war derjenige, der das damals zur BBC gebracht hat. Das war tatsächlich ein Kommentator, der dann ein Spiel von Arsenal beschreiben sollte. Sie haben es vorher geprüft, indem Sie einen blinden Menschen neben ihm gestellt haben und er das Spiel einer Schülermannschaft auf diese Art und Weise beschrieben hat. Und der Blinde hat den Daumen hoch gegeben, hat gesagt, ja, passt. Und dann haben Sie es so ausgeführt. Und interessanterweise gab es da auch Versuche in Deutschland. Aber vielleicht verrate ich damit was über meine eigene Recherche, die ich da mal angestellt habe. Gleichzeitig ist es ja aber so. Also das eine ist ja Worte zu finden für das Spiel auf dem Feld. Und das andere ist, dass wir logischerweise immer sehr von Ergebnissen her über diese Spiele schreiben. Es gibt ja noch ein anderes sehr empfehlenswertes Buch. Christoph Biermann, die Tabelle lügt immer über die Macht des Zufalls im Fußball. Und bei jedem eurer Bücher gibt es ungefähr 15 Millionen Dinge, die hätten passieren können und die zum Teil auch passiert sind. Also Beispiel, es fällt das 3 zu 3 im WM-Finale, aber es wird wegen Absatz nicht gegeben. War es eine korrekte Entscheidung, nicht mehr aufzulösen? Oder schauen wir uns WM-Finale 74 zum Beispiel nochmal an. Ich war erschüttert, wie gut Deutschland eigentlich war. Ich habe das immer so abgespeichert bekommen. Deutschland total glücklich Weltmeister. Die schießen auch ein Tor und das wird abgepfiffen. Und wenn du niederländische Quellen sagst, dann sagen die alle, pff, keine Ahnung warum. Also eigentlich waren die klar besser als wir in diesem Finale. Wie geht man denn, Tobi, wenn du magst, dass du gerne mal beginnen, wie geht man denn damit um, dass ja eigentlich in jedem Spiel auch die Geschichte steht, es hätte auch hundertfach anders ausgehen können und darin liegt eine ganz große Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit. Aber eigentlich macht es ja fast unmöglich, diese Spiele so zu erhöhen. Also wenn wir das anerkennen, dass der Zufall vielleicht der größte Mitspieler und Gegenspieler im Fußball sein kann, dann dürfen wir ja eigentlich gar nicht sagen, na, sie haben jetzt gewonnen, weil sie besser gekämpft haben oder weil Fritz Walter so tolle Pässe schon gespielt hat. Haben sie nicht letztlich einfach nur gewonnen, weil sie Glück hatten?
Jede Analyse muss ja erstmal vom Nachhinein aus getroffen werden. Und jede Analyse fügt vom Nachhinein Argumente ein, warum irgendetwas so passiert ist. Und es ist aber selten eine Analyse aus dem Moment heraus. Wenn man aus dem Moment heraus analysiert, dann muss man wirklich sehr, sehr stark ins Detail reingehen und dann wirklich, wie Ronny das ja auch beschrieben hat, dann fragen, warum habt ihr da nicht den langen Pass gespielt? Warum hast du da nicht die Passoption gemacht? Also jeder Ballkontakt im Fußball hat ja x Optionen, wie das ausgehen könnte. Und das ist auch so ein ganz enger Seiltanz. Weil du kannst natürlich die gesamte Menschheitsgeschichte, jedes Ereignis der Menschheit als reinen Zufall betrachten. Und du könntest ja aus dir allem einen Schmetterlingseffekt draus machen, wenn du das machen wollen würdest. Das macht es dann aber auch erstens langweilig, halt dann zu sagen, ja gut, sind glücklich Weltmeister geworden 1954 und dann haben sie sich ein bisschen feiern lassen. Das macht die ganze Geschichte natürlich ein bisschen langweiliger. Es spiegelt ja auch, es geht auch gegen den menschlichen Drang, Gründe für etwas wissen zu wollen, gegen diesen menschlichen Drang, Verständnis in ein Ereignis reinbringen zu wollen, einfach zu sagen, okay, da war halt dann die Absatzanzeigung zufälligerweise nicht, weil der Linienrichter gerade nicht richtig aufgepasst hat. Da muss man dann eben aufpassen, dass man dann nicht zu sehr in diese probabilistische Schiene reingeht. Aber andererseits auch macht es mir persönlich viel Spaß, Mythen zu entlarven, also dann nochmal zu gucken. So spiele ich selber nochmal an zu gucken von früher und zu gucken, okay, diese Mythen, die ich habe, was davon ist dann eigentlich wirklich mit meinen eigenen Augen in diesem Videomaterial belegbar? Das finde ich als Prozess auch sehr, sehr spannend.
Also ich finde, das entsteht in der Tat, wenn man sich alte Fußballspiele anschaut. Max, du hast das Finale 1974 erwähnt und man hat ein vorgefertigte Wertung darüber im Kopf. Dann ist man meistens erstaunt, dass es anders ist, was daran liegt, dass die Wertung ja immer 90 Minuten auf ein oder zwei Sätze reduziert und gar nicht so komplex sein kann wie ein Spiel. Die Gefahr aus Outdoor ist, glaube ich, immer, wenn ich jetzt in die Psychoanalyse reingehe, dass man nicht krampfhaft danach sucht, Mythen zu entlarven, macht mir auch einen Riesenspaß. Und ich hatte, glaube ich, so eine Phase in meinem Leben, als ich in Spanien Journalist war, da hatte ich unbewusst immer das Gefühl, ich will allen anderen erzählen, dass es ganz anders ist. Und davor muss man sich auch hüten, also, dass man krampfhaft daran geht. Ich glaube, dass man ein Spiel gerade in Büchern am besten beschreibt, indem man die Spannung versucht, selber zu erzeugen. Dass die Leser hechelnd mit dir über die Zeilen fliegen. Was passiert da, obwohl sie wissen, wie es ausgeht? Das ist ganz wichtig und dass man analysiert. Und da haben sicher auch Leute wie ihr mehr als wahrscheinlich sehr viele normale Zuschauer. Also könnte dem Leser sicher auch noch was bieten, indem er einfach analysiert. Aktionen von Spielern, von Mannschaften. Warum stehen die plötzlich so tief da drin? Oder einfach nur beschreiben, wie es tief ist. Und das dann die die eigentliche Bewertung oder Zusammenfassung auf zwei Zeilen. Die muss in einem Buch gar nicht drin sein. Also die finde ich muss man den Lesern immer oder kann man den Lesern immer selber überlassen dann. Also man muss mehr den Lesern was erzählen und seine eigene Meinung zurückhalten.
Und gleichzeitig ist ja aber auch noch eine weitere Komplexitätsebene, dass wir alle zwar mal Fußball gespielt haben und vielleicht auch nicht so unerfolgreich, wie das immer aussieht. Zumindest bei so Nerds wie Tobi und mir wird uns immer unterstellt, dass wir nie Erfolg hatten und gar nichts am Ball können. Ist aber auch egal. Aber wir bewerten ja einzelne Bewegungen von Sportlern, die aber logischerweise einen anderen Bewegungsapparat haben, ein anderes Ballgefühl und auch eine andere Wahrnehmung des kompletten Spiels. Also mir ist es zum Beispiel aufgefallen, Ronny, ich will es konkret machen, eben genau bei dieser Szene vom Tor gegen Polen bei der WM 2006. Du hast die Entstehung sehr schön gerade schon beschrieben. Was du dann später auch noch beschreibst, ist, wie Miroslav Klose den Ball zwischen den Beinen hindurch lässt. Ich glaube, du nennst es sogar eine der schwierigsten Bewegungen eines Fußballers. Ach nee, Entschuldigung, das war nicht das Tor gegen Polen, das war gegen Italien, als sie die Chance von Bernd Schneider herausspielen. Halbfinale jetzt. Bin ich gerade falsch abgebogen.
Jetzt dachte ich auch gerade, oh, was weißt du über mein Buch, was ich nicht weiß.
Aber das sieht man schon bei mir. Ich habe jetzt auch sehr viel gelesen in einer halben Zeit, muss ich zugeben an der Stelle. Also, aber da fand ich das so interessant, weil da ja eine Wertung mit drin steckt und auch eine Einordnung, eine Bewertung und du eben bis runter auf die Handlungsebene der Spieler gehst. Und jetzt weiß ich natürlich, dass du mit Miroslav Klose ausführlich gesprochen hast. Deswegen könnte es ja sein, dass er dir irgendwann mal gesagt hat, ja gut, das ist eigentlich somit das Schwierigste, manchmal den Ball gar nicht zu berühren und ihn einfach laufen zu lassen und damit eine Aktion zu starten. Gleichzeitig sind wir aber hier ja in dem, also in einem noch schwieriger zu beschreibenden Bereich des Spiels drin, auf der Mikroebene, die man ja auch manchmal gar nicht sieht. Wir sehen die Fernsehbilder. Das ist nicht die Perspektive, die die Spieler auf dem Feld haben. Also wie gehst du denn mit solchen Aspekten um?
Ich glaube, dass ich da schon meine eigene halbleinhafte Analysefähigkeit nicht mehr die Grundlage sind. Also wie sehe ich ein Spiel, was erscheint mir schwierig im Spiel? Und das beruht natürlich zum Großteil auf meiner Erfahrung als Zuschauer, aber auch als Gesprächspartner mit Spielern und auf der eigenen amateurhaften Erfahrung als Fußballer. Was ist schwer? Was ist leicht? Und gerade diese Bewegung von Miroslav Klose, das ist so ein komplexer Ablauf gewesen. Also er kriegt den Pass von Sebastian Kehl und er kann in den freien Raum starten und wird von Gattuso bedrängt. Und da wäre eigentlich die Aktion, die die meisten gemacht hätten, sie hätten versucht, den Ball mit dem starken rechten Fuß einfach an Gattuso vorbeizulegen und ihn davon zu sprinten. Und allein darauf, dass Miroslav Klose das nicht macht, sondern sich entscheidet, den Ball durch die eigenen Füße laufen zu lassen. Und er ist dann links von Gattuso. Gattuso total damit überrascht. Daraus habe ich schon geschlossen, wie schwierig das ist, allein auf diese Idee zu kommen. Und natürlich auch koordinativ. Du bist im Vollsprint und machst aber einen größeren Schritt, um den Ball durch die eigenen Beine zu lassen. Und im gleichen Moment schon fast ziehst du dann nach links wieder. Also koordinativ auch sehr komplex. Das habe ich mir jetzt tatsächlich nicht von Miroslav Klose anlernen lassen, sondern das ist meine eigene Beobachtung. Da kann es durchaus auch sein, dass Miroslav Klose zu mir gesagt hätte, hä, war doch gar nicht so schwierig, dass er da eine andere Perspektive hätte. Aber auf dem Umschlag des Buchs steht ja auch Ronald Reng und nicht Miroslav Klose. Also das ist mein Werk und meine Analyse. Und ja, die ist oft, oft wird die von anderen sicher anders gesehen.
Zeigt ja aber auch, wie genau man hingucken muss. Das haben wir ja auch, Tobi. Also wir gucken ja Spiele analytisch. Und wenn man aber über so eine Szene schreibt, dann zieht man die wieder und wieder und wieder. Auch manchmal ein Problem. Manchmal geht man zu sehr rein und verkopft sich so sehr und möchte noch mal erklären, was der Spieler ganz auf der anderen Seite Spielfeldseite gerade gemacht hat. Der hat mit dem Coach geredet. Ist das nicht Wahnsinn? Und dann irgendwann zwei Wochen später schaut man sein Manuskript und merkt, das hat keine Relevante, weder für diese Szene noch für den Leser. Und es war auch nicht mal besonders wichtig, dass er da noch gesprochen hat. Also wie gehst du denn mit diesen ja Mikrobeobachtungen innerhalb des Fußballs dann um?
Ich glaube, das sind aber doch schon wichtige Beobachtungen, weil das ist ja auch ein bisschen der Job eines, ich würde jetzt in dem Fall sagen, Sportreporter, dass er sich die Dinge anschaut, ein Stück weit, die nicht jeder anschaut, sondern das er da halt auch einen Mehrwert liefert in der Analyse. Und dann auch versucht da in der Analyse, das zu beleuchten, was man vielleicht nicht mit dem ersten Blick sieht. Und ich glaube, das ist ja auch unser täglich Brot, Max. Und er auch weiß ja auch, Ronny macht ja auch noch anderen Kram, als nur Bücher schreiben. Ich sehe es ja auch immer in dem DFL-Magazin sehr gerne, die Interviews und solche Geschichten. Da geht es ja dann auch um inhaltliche Arbeit. Es ist ja auch, man tut ja manchmal so, als ob da kein inhaltliche Arbeit drin steckt, aber wir bilden uns ja schon immer weiter, was ist gerade im Fußball angesagt, was sind denn die technischen Anforderungen, was sind die konditionellen Anforderungen usw. Was dann noch ein spannender Aspekt ist, wenn man Fußball geschichtlich rangeht, ist dann auch die Leistung, die in diesen Spielen getroffen werden, auch als Produkt ihrer Zeit zu begreifen. Ich hatte gerade mal im Schrank geguckt, Spieltage war glaube ich, das war das Buch mit dem Herrn Hönig drin, wo es ja auch dann um die…
Hörer meinst du, Heinz Hörer?
Hörer mein ich, Entschuldigung, Hörer, genau.
Hönig kenne ich nämlich nicht.
Nee, Hönig stimmt. Hörer, genau.
Ist dein Nachbar oder so, oder?
Da gibt es ja auch, glaube ich, die Episode, dass damals eben das Sportlersteak noch eine ganz große Geschichte war, also dass Sportler vor dem Spiel heraus einen Steak essen mussten. Kann man sich auch gar nicht vorstellen, wenn man sich das geht. Versuch mal vor einem Jogginglauf ein ganzes Steak zu futtern. Das andere, was mir gestern passiert ist, ironischerweise, ich war gestern Abend joggen und ich habe den ganzen Tag zu wenig getrunken und habe das dann relativ schnell gemerkt, Mist, ich hätte mal vielleicht einen Schluck trinken sollen, bevor ich laufen gehe und nicht ja dehydriert laufen gehen sollen. Und dann ist mir eingefallen, wieder 1954 war das gang und gäbe. Die haben nichts trinken dürfen den ganzen Tag lang. Die mussten auf Zitronenscheiben rumkauen, um halt ihr Durstgefühl zu stillen, weil es damals halt eben Stand der Wissenschaft war, dass der Körper möglichst wenig Flüssigkeit drin haben soll, damit man möglichst wenig schwitzt. Und dann unter diesen Bedingungen natürlich dann bestimmte Leistungen, auch der teilweise Schweizer Mittagssitze zu leisten, ist noch was ganz anderes als das, was wir heute leisten. Und das kann man ja auch versuchen, mit so einem Buch rüberzubringen.
Ja, kam damals, glaube ich, aus dem Militarismus oder aus der Armee. Da ist auch so eine Art Ertüchtigung durch Hartmachen dabei, nichts trinken. Das hielt sich aber in der Sportwissenschaft oder zumindest im Fußball bis Ende der 60er Jahre, glaube ich, diese Idee, dass die Spieler nichts trinken sollen. Man kann gespannt sein, was so in 50 Jahren über unseren heutigen Ernährungswissenschaftsstand gesagt wird, ob wir da auch so viel Quatsch anstellen. Zum Beispiel diese ganzen Protein-Obsessionen zum Beispiel, ne?
Ja, heute, gestern habe ich eine Mail bekommen, dass jetzt Real Madrid Urinale hat, die genau sagen, wie hydriert der Spieler ist. Und wenn der Spieler nicht gut hydriert ist, dann sagt das Urinal auf dem Klose fort, nein, bitte trinken Sie was.
Das hat aber der DFB noch netter gelöst in seiner Variante, in der er bei der Frauen-WM in Australien den Spielerinnen Erinnerungszettel aufs Zimmer gehängt hat. Und ich kenne auch ein Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, da gibt es eine Farbtabelle. Je nachdem, wie der Urin aussieht, ist es okay oder du musst mehr trinken. Also das kann man auch ohne solche Technik lösen. Aber das zeigt ja noch mal so ein ganz anderes Problem, eben der Kontext der Zeit. Also Franz Beckenbauer, der konnte ganz lange keine weißen Salmonen essen, weil der musste die immer im Training zwischendurch essen, eben als Trinkersatz. Und er hat das eben gehasst, man ist eh schon durstig. Und dann muss man sich auch noch letztlich sämtlichen Speichel mit dieser trockenen Semmel aus dem Mund ziehen lassen. Aber das war eben damals Gang und Gebe. Und gleichzeitig hast du aber ja gerade angesprochen, Tobi, wenn wir über historische Spiele sprechen, neben allen Interpretationen, die im Nachhinein draufgepackt werden, ist es für uns ja aber auch schwierig oder die Aufgabe, sie eben im Kontext der Zeit zu sehen. Also sprich, wenn ich das WM-Finale 1974 als Beispiel sportlich bewerten möchte, dann muss ich mindestens von dieser WM noch viele Spiele gesehen haben. Im besten Fall hätte ich eigentlich sogar noch mehr mir angeschaut. Da gibt es ja aber keinen Anfang und kein Ende. Also wie machst du sowas?
Da muss man aufpassen, dass man nicht in ein Loch reinfällt manchmal. Also manchmal muss man sich dazu zwingen, weil das ist nicht immer vergnügungsteuerpflichtig, ein Spiel anzugucken, das 50 Jahre alt ist, von dem du auch weißt, wie es ausgeht, von dem du auch im Idealfall weißt, in der 30. Minute wird ein Tor fallen, bis dahin wird gar nichts passieren. Da muss man sich dazu zwingen. Aber du kannst da auch in Löcher reinfallen. Ich habe sämtliche Spiele der polnischen Nationalmannschaft um die WM 74 geschaut, weil ich ebenso beeindruckt war von deren Leistung, wie sie da in dieser Wasserschlacht geleistet haben. Unter widrigsten Bedingungen, du da schon gemerkt hast, okay, da steckt eigentlich ein technisch viel brillanteres Team hinter. Und da musst du aber dann schon reingucken, weil ich glaube, das ist auch eine der besten Quellen, neben dem, da ist Ronny noch viel besser als ich, neben dem Sprechen mit Spielern, halt wirklich diese Spiele zu gucken. Weil in den Spielen selbst steckt ja auch das meiste drin, weil das ist ja auch das, worum nachher die ganze Geschichte sich dreht. Also, worum du kannst die 54er-Geschichte nur schreiben, weil Deutschland diese Fußballspiele gewinnt. Genau dasselbe mit 74. Und das ist ja das, worauf dann alles darauf vorbereitet wird. Und da dann diese Spiele halt reinzuschauen und dann eben nicht nur dieses eine Spiel zu schauen. Weil wenn du das eine Spiel schaust, das kann ja immer, wie wir es vorhin schon gesagt haben, Zufälligkeiten passieren. Manchmal ist es auch so, dass das eben nicht die Mannschaft widerspiegelt, dass die Mannschaft eigentlich noch ganz andere Art des Fußballspielens hat. Das ist ja bei der deutschen Nationalmannschaft. Die hat ja im Verlaufe dieses Turniers 74 sehr viele verschiedene Evolutionsstufen gehabt, die sie haben musste, um dieses Turnier erfolgreich bestreiten zu können. Und das dann in den Kontext setzen zu können, ist, glaube ich, schon sehr, sehr wichtig. Und das ist ja auch ganz gut, dass das spätestens ab 1962, 1966 sehr gut geht. Und ja, genau.
Ronny, wie näherst du dich diesem Problem?
Naja, das Spiel an sich steht ja bei mir eigentlich nie im Vordergrund der Bücher. Also ich versuche ja gerade bei diesen zwei Büchern, die wir heute besprechen, die Zeit einzufangen. Deswegen ist die Analyse, wie war der Stand des Fußballs damals, ist eher ein Randthema. 2006 konnte ich das tatsächlich auch aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung machen. Damals war ich ja rasender Fußballreporter in Barcelona, als sie zum ersten Mal mit ihrer sehr spezifischen Spielform passen und weiter passen, Positionsspiel, diese Wichtigkeit, Erfolg hatten. Deswegen war das also damals für mich ein sehr großes Thema und ich hatte das Gefühl, ich bin da drin. Mourinho war damals zum ersten Mal, war eine Sensation damals mit diesem Verteidigen im Block, also eine höhere Art der Organisation des Spielsystems. Und aus diesem Wissen in meinem Hinterkopf heraus, glaube ich, konnte ich die Spiele dann bewerten. Habe sie aber tatsächlich noch mal anders gesehen, als ich die 2006 gesehen habe, die Spiele der Deutschen Nationalmannschaft. Also damals war ich sehr begeistert von dem Klinsmann-Fußball. Jetzt, 20 Jahre später, erschien es mir dann doch sehr wuchtig, also wirklich sehr sehr vehement. Aber jetzt weder super organisiert, noch irgendwie spielerisch hoch, hoch brillant.
Aber das ist die Rezeption in der Zeitgeschichte, weil die Begeisterung für den 2006er-Fußball ist halt nicht erklärbar, wenn man nicht dann die Dinge anschaut, die davor waren und sich zum Beispiel dieses März-Italien 1 zu 4-Spiel da anschaut. Da habe ich noch sehr genaue Erinnerungen, wo ich damals war und das geguckt habe und wie wir dann auch gesagt haben, ok, 2006, wir brauchen uns gar nicht zur WM anmelden, wir fliegen in der Vorrunde raus. Das ist ja auch immer dann die Frage, wie ist denn vorher die Rezeption? Und das ist gerade bei diesen Nationalmannschaftsthemen sehr, sehr wichtig. Zum Beispiel auch die 66er-Mannschaft, die ja Vize-Weltmeister geworden ist und auch die 70er-Mannschaft, die heute sehr, sehr hoch auch in der Fußballgeschichtsschreibung sind, die sind auch teilweise erklärbar dadurch, dass vor dem Turnier alle gesagt haben, da wird nichts, brauchst du gar nicht hinfahren erst, weil eben die Erwartungen so niedrig waren und dann hast du eben auch leichte Spiele und dann heißt es danach eben, hey, die waren ja so gut, weil halt wir vorher erwartet haben, dass sie schlecht sind.
Ja, ja und die 2006er wurden natürlich auch aus dem Rausch dieses Sommers bewertet. Also sie haben ja durchaus auch rauschhaft gespielt in dem Sinn, dass das sie wirklich dieses Tempo, diese Wucht ihr prägendes Element war und wenn natürlich drum herum alle berauscht sind, dann sieht man das auch viel wohlenwollender, als es vielleicht, wenn man es jetzt knallhart sachlich analysiert oder vergleicht mit dem Fußball, der dann 2012 von Deutschland bei der Europameisterschaft gespielt wurde, der vielleicht deutlich besser war, aber auch von den Leuten nicht mehr so erinnert wird, weil sie halt im Halbfinale gegen Italien relativ dilettantisch in zwei Szenen ausgeschieden sind.
Aber da kommen wir ja eigentlich bei einem wirklich interessanten Befund raus. Also wir haben eine Multiperspektive auf einzelne Fußballspiele. Jeder auf dem Feld hat schon mal anders gesehen, manchmal widerspricht sich das. Wir haben bis auf die Mikroebene hinein einzelne Bewegungen, die analysiert werden können, aber auch nicht müssen, denn sie können eine Bedeutung haben, müssen sie aber nicht. Wir haben einen Zufall, der eigentlich zu jeder Zeit mit einem Fingerschnipsen alles komplett verändern könnte. Und wir haben das Narrativ, das immer von hinten erzählt wird, also vom Ergebnis her. Und im Nachhinein wird dann alles in diesem Lichte gesehen. Plus dieses Narrativ verändert sich dann noch über die Jahre und Jahrzehnte. Ronny, muss man da nicht eigentlich bei dem Befund rauskommen, dass alles im Fußball Fiktion ist?
Naja, die Ergebnisse stehen da, die Statistiken sind da. Also Fußball ist ein sehr faktionales Spiel. Also es ist ja eher was für statistische Nerds schon gedacht. Aber wir Menschen interpretieren Dinge. Das ist aber auch nichts Neues. Und wir Menschen schauen alle mit anderen Blick auf bestimmte Dinge. Und wir rezipieren sehr viel einfach aus unserer Erinnerung und die Erinnerung fälscht. Und dagegen muss man als Autor versuchen, so gut es geht, anzukämpfen gegen diese Dinge. Und dann kann man, glaube ich, schon ein sehr faktenintensives Buch zusammenkriegen, wo von der Fiktion da nicht mehr viel übrig bleibt.
Tobi hat schon genickt. Ich habe ja auch ein bisschen provoziert mit der Frage. Du siehst es ähnlich.
Ja, natürlich. Man muss sich dann immer bewusst machen, dass man selbst Vorurteile mit in so ein Buch reinbringt oder auch in jeder Form von journalistischer Arbeit. Und ich versuche, das ja auch mal sehr, sehr transparent zu gestalten, in welche Art von Fußball ich besonders mag und welche ich es nicht besonders mag. Da muss dann der Leser nicht oder auch der Rezipient nicht mit einstimmen, aber er weiß dann, okay, der Herr Escher, der mag jetzt diesen Fußball besonders oder der mag diesen Fußball besonders nicht. Da kann man ja auch dann transparent mit umgehen, weil man kriegt das nicht ganz raus, dass man natürlich selbst bestimmte Sichtweisen auf Themen hat, selbst bestimmte Blickwinkel abdeckt und nicht abdeckt. Im einen Fall dann eher das Fußball-Analytische, das dann eben in diese Arbeiten mit reinkriegt, stärker als das bei anderen Autoren der Fall wäre.
Ja, aber deswegen kaufen ja auch manche Leute dann die Bücher von bestimmten Autoren von dir, weil sie genau das wollen, weil sie es entweder in ihrer Meinung bestätigt werden wollen oder weil du eine Sicht hast, die sie selber nicht haben, weil du sozusagen Mehrwert hast für sie. Von daher ist das nur menschlich, dass unsere eigenen Sichtweisen unser Buch prägen und das soll auch so sein. Also wenn es nur objektive Bücher gäbe, dann wäre es ja egal, ob Tobias Escher, Max Ost oder Ronald Reng das Buch schreiben. Das ist ja gerade auch interessant für die Leser, die Sichtweise des Autors, wenn er ihnen was zu bieten hat tatsächlich.
Und gleichzeitig ist ja auch das nur das Spiel in Anführungszeichen und wo wir aber ja auch schon am Anfang unseres Gesprächs waren, war das, mit dem dieses Spiel aufgeladen wird. Also wir sprechen eben nicht mehr nur über Fußballspiele, sondern wir sprechen über kollektive Erinnerungen. Und wir sprechen vor allem im modernen Fußball. Du hast es vorhin ja auch erklärt, Ronny, warum dem so ist. Sprechen wir über kollektive Erinnerungen, die sich nicht nur mehr nur auf Fußballfans beziehen. Du sprichst es selber an, ich glaube im Nachwort oder im Epilog des Buches, dass jeder, mit dem du gesprochen hast oder dem du erzählt hast, dass du über die WM 2006 schreibst, der kam mit seiner persönlichen Erinnerung. Wie war es denn, dieses Buch zu schreiben? Und hast du da auch erlebt, also hast du da auch eine Multiperspektive erlebt? Also haben sich zum Beispiel Menschen mit einem italienischen Migrationshintergrund anders an die WM erinnert? Das ist so meine persönliche Erfahrung, als es viele andere in deinem Umfeld getan haben.
Na zunächst mal habe ich das Buch geschrieben ohne meine eigene Erinnerung. Also ich schreibe ja, in meinen Büchern ist es immer völlig egal, was ich erlebt habe oder was ich fühle, sondern es ging darum, zu versuchen zu sehen, was möglichst viele Perspektiven zu finden, interessante Perspektiven, persönliche Geschichten zu finden. Und ich glaube schon, wenn du das Buch liest, dann wirst du ganz unterschiedliche Perspektiven gehabt haben, weil die Leute natürlich mit ihrem eigenen Leben beschäftigt waren. Also ich habe einen 17-Jährigen namens Julian Nagelsmann in dem Buch, dem dieses ganze Training, sage ich jetzt übertrieben, dieser ganze Trainerquatsch, was Jürgen Klinsmann da macht, nicht interessiert, weil er ist ja Fußballspieler und nicht Fußballtrainer. Und du hast aber andere drin, wie Bernd Schneider oder Thomas Hitzelsberger, die das aufsaugen, was ihn Joachim Löw und Jürgen Klinsmann da präsentieren, weil das völlig neu für sie ist, eine völlig neue wissenschaftlichere Fußballarbeit. Deswegen hast du da auch ganz unterschiedliche Perspektiven auf diesen Sommer. Und ich habe zufälligerweise sogar jemanden getroffen, für den dieser Sommer ganz traurig war, eigentlich einer der größten Fußballfans. Und der gedacht hat, in diesem Sommer macht er etwas ganz Besonderes. Er hat versucht, Fan-Camps zu organisieren, also Zeltlager, wo Fans übernachten. Und das führte zu seiner Pleite, zum Bankrott. Also auch da hoffe ich, gezeigt zu haben, dass auch die kollektiven Erlebnisse individuell völlig unterschiedlich erlebt wurden. Wobei, wenn diese Frage immer kam von Leuten, woran schreibst du denn über den Sommer 2006? Oder habe ich bla bla bla? Da kamen dann schon immer sehr ähnliche Geschichten, wie sie auf der Straße nach dem Sieg gegen Argentinien geschrien haben. Oder wie sie bei sich zwei Mexikaner zuhause aufgenommen haben, ohne Geld von denen verlangen. Wie sie irgendwie halb betrunken mit Leuten aus Costa Rica, die Nacht durchtanzt haben oder sowas. Das war dann schon, glaube ich, ein das prägende kollektive Gefühl oder Erlebnis damals. Ihr könnt jetzt mir gerne auch noch mal erzählen, was ihr erlebt habt 2006.
Es brennt unter den Nägeln. Aber ich möchte nur eine Perspektive rein geben. Und das zeigt aber auch, glaube ich, wie schwierig es ist, dem Anspruch gerecht zu werden, so ein Zeitgefühl wiederzugeben. Also ich kenne ein italienisch stämmiges Paar, die hatten ein Restaurant, die mussten dicht machen. Im Sommer, nach dem Sommer 2006, weil tatsächlich die kommen aus einer ländlichen Region. Und da hieß es, nachdem Italien Deutschland rausgenommen hat im Halbfinale, die droven Italiener, die wurden boykottiert. Da sind die Leute alle dann zum Griechen gegangen, der ein Dorf weiter war. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt auch nur eine einzelne Erinnerung, aber das zeigt ja schon, wie schwierig es ist und dass man eigentlich auch nie alles abbilden kann, weil du sprichst es zwar auch an, wie sich da der, ich sag mal so, der freundschaftliche Ton verschärft hat, rund um dieses Halbfinale, nach der Sperre gegen Thorsten Frings und so weiter und so fort. Aber das ist eben auch eine Perspektive, die aber dann nicht so ganz zu der Leichtigkeit passt. Ja, das wollte ich dem eigentlich nur daneben stellen.
Als Buchautor würde ich erstmal die Geschichte von deinen italienischen Freunden von allen Seiten hinterfragen, ob das wirklich der einzige Grund war, dass da wegen dieses Fußballspiel weniger Leute hingegangen sind. Erscheint mir sehr eindimensional, diese Erklärung. Da wäre ich erstmal skeptisch als Buchautor. Aber das ist ja die Idee des Buches, dass du hast also eine kollektive Erinnerung und du hinterfragst die. Und natürlich musst du als Autor nicht Angst haben. Es gibt aber 82,3 Millionen Deutsche damals. Da wird es wahrscheinlich noch ganz viel unterschiedliche Erinnerungen geben. Nein, du bildest ein Spektrum von Erinnerungen ab. Ich habe versucht, auch die großen Themen der Zeit abzubilden, die offenbar damals so leicht endende oder zurückgehende Arbeitslosigkeit zum Beispiel, Musikgeschmack, Fußballrevolution durch Klinsmann verändert sich, unsere Trainingslehre, all das. Und dann können alle Leser, wenn sie das lesen, das mit ihren eigenen Erinnerungen verknüpfen, hinterfragen und sagen, na ja, aber ich habe es ganz anders erlebt oder aber da erkenne ich mich wieder. Also das ist ja die Aufgabe eines Buches, weitere Erinnerungen auszulösen und nicht dieser Allmachtsanspruch, ich habe alles abgedeckt.
Plus Problembär Bruno, spielt natürlich auch eine heimliche Hauptrolle in diesem Buch. Und gleichzeitig hast du, Tobi, vorhin etwas gesagt, da habe ich jetzt auch im Verlauf der Sendung schon mehrfach nochmal dran gedacht. Du meintest, dass wir aktuell in einer Zeit leben, in der alles politisiert werden soll und dem würde ich zustimmen. Gleichzeitig sehe ich aber im Fußball, an ganz vielen Ecken zumindest, den Wunsch, genau das nicht zuzulassen. Am prominentesten natürlich mit dem DFB, der jetzt jegliche politische Diskussionen rund um einen möglichen WM-Boykott abgeräumt hat, mehr oder weniger mit den Worten, wir haben damit schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, wir sind doch nur Sportler. Wenn wir aber dann aber auch festhalten, welche Bedeutung der Fußball aktuell hat, als eben Ort in der Gesellschaft, du hast es ja vorhin selber ausgeführt, können wir denn dann die Akteure dieses Spiels damit durchkommen lassen und dürfen wir denn dann das Spiel noch als Spiel sehen, zumindest wenn wir den größeren Rahmen aufmachen und eben nicht nur einen Spielbericht liefern wollen?
Ich glaube, das verläuft auch immer wie vieles im Leben in Zyklen. Also gerade ist eben in vielen Bereichen vieles politisiert. Also man versucht ja wirklich sehr viele Lebensbereiche in politische Entscheidungen mit reinzuziehen und dann auch sei es Ernährung, sei es das tägliche Verhalten, und so weiter. Das ist der eine Bereich, wo dann natürlich manchmal auch von Sportlern gefordert wird, sich zu positionieren in Dinge, für die sie nicht zuständig sind. Muss man ja auch dann in dem Maße ganz ehrlich sagen, das sind alles junge Kerls, die Millionen damit verdienen, weil sie besonders gut Fußball spielen können. Das heißt weder, dass sie besonders gut sich mit anderen Themen auskennen, noch dass sie da wirklich die richtigen Ansprechpartner sind. Aber du hast es ja auch gerade schon angedeutet, der DFB hat da natürlich eine andere Stellung als Verband und auch als politische Kraft, die auch selber politische Forderungen immer wieder stellen. Jetzt gerade in der Debatte, DFL, DFB sind da sehr stark in der Debatte mit drin, was Stadiengänge, was der Umgang mit Fans angeht und so weiter. Da ist ja mit der Innenministerkonferenz viel Debatte. Also der DFB ist ein politischer Akteur, deswegen kann man da, denke ich, andere Ansprüche ranhegen als an einen durchschnittlichen Fußballspieler. Ich muss meine Gedanken so ein bisschen sortieren, weil ich nicht, weil das ist ein ganz hochkomplexes Thema, dass ich da auch nichts Falsches sagen möchte. Weil natürlich der Fußball, der sich einerseits sehr, sehr einfach macht dann und dann so tut, ja, wir sind halt nur der Fußball, aber natürlich ist der Fußball in politische Gegebenheiten, und gerade die Verbände, wenn wir jetzt gucken, der Umgang mit Iran bei der WM, die sich fußballerisch für diese WM qualifiziert haben, aber die aus politischen Gründen nicht an dieser WM werden teilnehmen können. Dass Fans halt aus bestimmten Ländern nicht an einer WM in den USA teilnehmen können, weil sie in dieses Land nicht reinkommen. Was eine sehr große Ironie ist, wenn man bedenkt, dass sie es nach Katar geschafft haben. So, da sind viele, viele Aspekte mit drin, die diskussionswürdig sind, die ja auch zeigen, dass der Fußball und Politik nicht verschränkt sind. Aber trotzdem ist es auch ein Teil unserer Zeitgeschichte, einfach derzeit, dass sehr viele Themen sehr kontrovers diskutiert werden, was manchmal gut, manchmal nervig sein kann. Aber dass dann auch natürlich Kante von Leuten erwartet wird, die diese Kante nicht liefern können oder wollen.
Ja, auch interessant, wie sich das verändert hat. 2006 in einer, wie ich es vorhin ausgeführt habe, weniger polisierten, aufgeheizten Atmosphäre war der mündige Fußballer, war immer das Wort, durchaus ein Ziel, auch für viele Fußballer. Also auch Oliver Bierhoff als Teammanager der Nationalmannschaft hat den Fußballern Bücher geschenkt, selbst die Buddenprocks von Thomas Mann und so was. Weil damals auch im Fußball diese Idee vorherrschte, der ganzheitliche Fußballer ist ein besserer Spieler sozusagen. Also wer als Mensch reift, wird auch als Fußballer reifen. Das war ein Ziel damals, den mündigen Fußballer zu schaffen. Auch bei der Europameisterschaft 2012 zum Beispiel, haben die Spieler ja so Exposés gekriegt über die politische Lage in der Ukraine und in Polen und so was. Und die Zeiten wurden politisch wieder viel aufgeheizter. Es gibt viel mehr, die Politik übernimmt unser ganzes Leben. Und jetzt wird es für einen Fußballer einfach wahnsinnig anstrengend, zu irgendwelchen politischen Dingen Stellung zu nehmen, weil er sofort, egal was er sagt, er hat einen Teil der Bevölkerung emotional gegen sich. Und dann ist es ja eigentlich ein menschlich rationaler Schritt für einen Fußballer, dessen Kernaufgabe es ist, gut Fußball zu spielen, diesen Brennpunkt aus seinem Leben zu schaffen. Also ich biete, egal was ich sage, ich biete Angriffsflächen. Und ich muss mich mit einem Konflikt beschäftigen, der mich im Zweifelsfall in meiner Leistung hemmt. Und diesen Reflex erleben wir natürlich auch beim DFB. Der DFB wird jetzt gefordert, Stellung dazu zu nehmen. Wie ist das denn eine Weltmeisterschaft in Amerika? Und da dürfen Fans aus Tunesien nur einreisen, wenn sie eine Kaution von 15.000 Euro hinterlegen. Wenn der DFB jetzt kann dazu Stellung nehmen und sagen, ja, ich finde das unverschämt, aber er wird dadurch sozusagen, er schafft mehr Aufregung, aber er kann eigentlich nicht wirklich was ändern, weil sein Einfluss auf die FIFA extrem begrenzt ist. Und da ist natürlich dann auch der Reflex bei einem Verband, sich diesen gesellschaftspolitischen Stellung, die er hat, erst mal zu entziehen. Und sagen, ich schaffe eigentlich nur Schlagzeilen, aber keine große Veränderung. Und die Gefahr ist natürlich dann da, dass der Verband irgendwann sich auch nicht mehr bemüht, Stellung zu nehmen oder Dinge zu versuchen, Dinge zu beeinflussen, gesellschaftspolitisch, wo er eigentlich wirklich was verändern könnte. Dass er zum Beispiel irgendwann auch nicht mehr gegen Rassismus Stellung nehmen würde im Sport, was er aber immer noch eigentlich jetzt noch tut. Also das sehe ich zum einen erklärbar, dieser Rückzug wieder ins private quasi, aus dem politischen raus, weil es da wenig zu gewinnen gibt aus Sicht dieser Protagonisten und andererseits gleichzeitig eine Gefahr. Der Sport kann auch nicht diesen Kampf, wenn er sagt, wir haben mit Politik nichts zu tun, das kann er nicht gewinnen, weil das ist nicht so. Er ist Teil unseres Lebens und er muss bis zu einem gewissen Grad durch die Handlung oder teilweise auch durch, was er sagt, Stellung nehmen.
Was aber dann ja zu der vielleicht dann Abschlussfrage führen kann. Jetzt wird es schwierig. Ein Blick in die Zukunft. Also wir haben ja jetzt ganz gut nachgezeichnet, welche Bedeutung Erinnerung an Fußballereignisse, an Sportereignisse hat. Auch eben nicht nur im Fußballkontext, sondern eben auch in einem gesellschaftlichen Kontext. Und jetzt sind wir in der Aktualität gelandet, wo wir eben sehen, es gibt vielleicht wieder eine Rückentwicklung. Und du hast vorhin, Tobias, vom Zyklus gesprochen. Das kann man auch hier feststellen. Also 2006 wollten wir mündige... Wir haben viele Spieler, ich kann mich erinnern über all die Artikel über Rainer Bonhoff, Uli Hoeneß, Paul Breitner, weil das Abiturienten waren, die erstmal Fußballprofis wurden, da war es auch schon mal so. Da hatten wir auch eben genau diese Entwicklung und eine spätere Rückentwicklung. Wenn wir jetzt konstatieren, aktuell scheint es so zu sein, dass Kriege dann doch wieder als Kriege und nicht als Fußballspiel geführt werden, dass Nationalismus definitiv vorherrscht und leider auch Dinge wie Rassismus vielleicht zumindest sichtbarer sind. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie so verbreiteter sind als früher, aber sie sind sichtbarer. Wäre dann vielleicht auch damit zu rechnen, dass das Erinnern an Fußball und Sportereignisse in Zukunft wieder weniger wichtig wird?
Ich würde jetzt erstmal die Frage stellen, wie wichtig es überhaupt ist. Also es ist ja schon noch ein Nischenthema, würde ich behaupten. Also es gibt auch ganz, ganz viele Fußballfans, die von der Vergangenheit nichts wissen wollen. Also ich bin da ganz ehrlich, es liegt vielleicht auch an mir, aber meine Fußballgeschichtsbücher sind nicht meine bestverkauften Bücher. Also der Verlag ist immer schon ganz froh, wenn ich mit einer anderen Idee um die Ecke komme und dann sage, dann machen wir wieder was anderes, was zur aktuellen Situation, also was Gegenwartgeschichte ist und nicht Vergangenheitsgeschichte. Aber natürlich ist auch das Erinnern immer zyklenverbunden. Also gerade es gibt ja auch immer so eine Flucht in die Vergangenheit in manchen Phasen, so eine Art von Eskapismus, wo man dann ja auch schaut, was wie war es früher. Das erlebt man ja auch ein Stück weit derzeit, dass so eine Vergangenheitsverklärung manchmal stattfindet. Gerade im Fußball, im englischen Diskurs ist das gerade ganz, ganz stark. Wenn man in die sozialen Medien guckt, da wird gerade sehr, sehr stark gehypt. Der Fußball der 2000er, diese Barclays-Ära in der Premier League. Das ist ein großes, großes Thema. Das heißt, der Fußball heute ist nicht mehr so, wie er vor 20 Jahren war, als der Fußball noch gut war, in Anführungszeichen. Und das sind ja auch immer so Spiegelbilder der Gegenwart. Wenn man sich dann versucht, in so eine Vergangenheit zu fliehen und das dementsprechend ist das Interesse, das steigt und ebbt dann wieder ab. Und natürlich diese Jubiläen dann, ich sage immer so, so fies das klingt, wenn die, wenn eine Generation in das Rentenalter geht und dann auch ein bisschen Zeit hat, dann lesen sie auch gerne mal dann Bücher, wie war das eigentlich früher in meiner Kindheit. Und dann ist immer der richtige Zeitpunkt da, um an die Turniere von früher zu erinnern. So 50 Jahre ist immer so ein guter Zeitpunkt, dann nochmal das Thema aufleben zu lassen. Das Fliegt dann immer in Zeiten und das wird es natürlich dann auch wieder geben, dass dann irgendwann die 2006er WM jetzt kommt jetzt wieder und dann wird es wieder vergessen. Und dann in 30, 40 Jahren, wenn dann die nächste WM in Deutschland stattfindet, dann wird das wieder rausgeholt.
Also Ronny, du hast quasi die Grundlage für später.
Genau, dann hoffentlich in 30 Jahren wird das Buch dann wieder rausgeholt. Aber für die meisten Menschen ist Fußball Gegenwart, es ist Zeitvertreib. Also die schalten den Fernseher ein, um ein Fußballspiel zu sehen. Und sehr viele schalten sogar schon aus, bevor die Interviews kommen danach, wahrscheinlich die Mehrheit. Und die wenigstens beschäftigen sich mit dem Fußball, mit der Geschichte oder tiefer, auch selbst über das Spiel hinaus noch mit Taktik. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, diese Sendung hier werden nicht ganz so viele Einschalten, Leute werden nicht ganz so viele Einschalten, wie beim WM-Finale 2014 in Deutschland, Argentinien, die 28 Millionen. Auch das ist ein kleiner Beleg dafür, dass für die meisten Leute es findet in der Gegenwart statt. Und auch wenn Fußball eine deutlich höhere gesellschaftliche Bedeutung hat, was man zum Beispiel daran sieht, dass beim WM-Finale 1954, von dem Tobi erzählt hat, da ist der Bundeskanzler natürlich nicht hingefahren und der Bundespräsident auch nicht, weil es war nur Fußball. So und wenn jetzt Deutschland in Amerika ins Finale kommt, erwartet die Bundesrepublik, dass der Bundeskanzler dahin fährt und Deutschland repräsentiert. Also auch wenn Fußball eine deutlich höhere gesellschaftliche Bedeutung hat, dann ist es immer nur Fußball. Und wenn tunesische Fans oder iranische Fans nicht bei dem Turnier in Amerika dabei sein können, dann ist es traurig. Aber es wird keinen Einfluss auf die Weltpolitik haben. Was Donald Trump sonst macht, was er zum Beispiel jetzt im Iran macht, hat deutlich größere Auswirkungen auf eine deutlich größere Gruppe von Menschen. Also, dem müssen wir uns auch immer fair gewertigen. Deswegen, der Kern des Ganzen ist immer noch das Spiels, an dem erfreuen sich sehr viele Menschen. Und sehr viele Menschen wollen auch gar nicht wissen, wie genau es abgelaufen ist.
Das ist noch, da will ich gleich noch einhaken, weil das ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ist, weil ja der Fußball und die Bedeutung des Fußballs ja auch sehr stark durch die Rezeption lebt. Also, der Fußball an sich hat keine lebensverändernde Funktion. Wenn es morgen keiner berichten würde über diese WM, dann würde das auch keinen interessieren, dann würde dadurch auch keine Geschichte entstehen. Wenn morgen keiner mehr über den Irankrieg berichtet, dann würde die Straße von Humus immer noch gesperrt sein. Unsere Benzinpreise werden immer noch erhöht, es würden immer noch Menschen dort sterben. Also, das hat ja einen realen Bezug auf die Lebenswirklichkeit von so vielen Menschen und der Fußball lebt ja eben auch davon, dass es halt da eine Rezeption gibt und eine Rezeptionsgeschichte auch gibt und diese Ereignisse, die wir da in den Fußball rein interpretieren, können ja nur so stattfinden, weil es dann Autoren oder auch Journalisten oder auch Menschen gibt, die eben diesen Ereignissen Bedeutung verleihen wollen. Und das ist glaube ich ein riesiger Unterschied, weswegen ja auch diese Geschichtsschreibung da ganz wichtig ist, weil dadurch ja dann auch überhaupt erst diese Bedeutung des Fußballs verstärkt wird.
Fußball eignet sich sehr gut, aber für das, was Menschen lieben, nämlich Mythen und Verschwörungstheorien im Kleinen. Also ich erinnere mich bei dem Buch 1974, was sich ja um dieses eine Spiel, Bundesrepublik gegen DDR, dreht. Wirklich auf jeder Lesung wurde ich danach gefragt, sagen Sie mal, haben Sie eigentlich die Bundesdeutschen damals absichtlich verloren? Und jeder, der nur drei Sekunden darüber nachgedacht hätte, mit ein paar Fakten, müsste zum Schluss kommen. Nein, natürlich ist unmöglich, dass sie absichtlich verloren haben. Sprichen so viele Fakten dagegen. Und trotzdem wollen die Menschen diesen Mythos am Leben haben, weil sie es faszinierend finden, weil wir uns gerne ungewöhnliche, absurde Geschichten erzählen. Und dazu eignet sich Fußball natürlich fantastisch.
Und da auch wieder total die Rezeptionsgeschichte nach Land. Wenn du nach Polen gehst und die Leute 74 fragst, die sehen das als riesigen Beschiss an, dass diese Wasserschlacht stattgefunden hat. Und das war ja natürlich auch dafür da, um die Polen da klein zu halten, um den Ostenblock klein zu halten und so weiter und so fort.
Und kann man auch nicht komplett widersprechen, aber dementsprechend seid ihr eben die modernen Geschichtenerzähler in einem Feld, in dem es sehr viele interessiert. Aller, allerletzte Frage. 2024 sind eure beiden Bücher erschienen, zu 1974 und zu 1954. Wann, Tobi, hast du herausgefunden, dass Ronny auch ein Buch schreibt und wie groß war deine Erleichterung, dass ihr nicht beide 54 oder beide 74 gemacht habt?
Ich glaube, Ronny verkauft, glaube ich, so oder so genug Bücher. Der hat genügend Fans. Und für 54 muss ich auch sagen, das war ein Liebhaberprojekt. Das muss ich auch noch mal unterschreiten. Das habe ich dem Verlag auch abgerungen, dass ich das machen darf, weil auch da völlig klar war, dass das kein riesengroßer Gassenschlager wird, wo die Leute einen wochenlangen Buchhandel anstehen. Da wäre es, glaube ich, relativ egal gewesen, wenn da noch ein Buch dazu käme.
Ich habe mich tatsächlich gefreut, aus der Ferne, ohne ihn zu kennen, für Tobias, weil ich ihn bis dahin nur wahrgenommen hatte, als jemand, der sehr gut taktische Entwicklungen im Spiel erklärt, also das Spiel an sich erklärt. Und ich es immer gut finde, wenn Autoren was Neues probieren. Also von daher habe ich mich völlig selbstlos darüber gefreut.
Das ist wucherschehen, aber das ist kein Angstschweiß auf der Stirn gehabt, dass er aber ihr habt euch schon gekannt vor dieser Sendung, oder?
Nein, nicht persönlich.
Ich war mal bei einer Lesung von von ihm.
Das ist inkognito.
Ich war dadurch gut.
Ich glaube, nicht jeder auf der Lesung geht zum Autor und stellt sich erst mal vor.
Aber es gibt die Leute gibt es immer, die das machen.
Ja, kann aber auch sehr peinlich enden. Ich war mal auf einer Lesung, da hat sich leider der Autor gar nicht mehr dran erinnert, dass wir schon mal was beruflich zusammen gemacht hatten. Da war mir ein bisschen unangenehm, dass ich gewartet habe, dass alle zum Signieren wegfahren, damit ich dann niemanden aufhalte.
Du hast die ganze selbstverständlich angesprochen. Hi, wie geht's?
Ja, fast so schön, dass wir uns mal persönlich kennenlernen, habe ich gesagt. Und ich habe es direkt in der ersten Sekunde habe ich schon gemerkt, oh Gott, das war ein Riesenfehler. Jetzt habe ich uns beide in eine unangenehme Situation gebracht. Naja, sagen wir es so. Ich war dann relativ schnell aus der Tür und wieder auf dem Fahrrad nach Hause. Aber ja, dann ist es ja schön, dass ihr euch jetzt kennengelernt habt. Ich hätte das gar nicht für möglich gehalten, ehrlich gesagt, weil ihr in meinem Leben so eine große Rolle spielt. Ihr beide und das ja auch in unterschiedlicher Art und Weise. Wir haben hier mit Tobias Escher den aktuell noch führenden an Gastauftritten im Rasenfunk. Das müsste jetzt dein 64. Auftritt gewesen sein. Tobi, vielen Dank dafür. Und mit Ronald Reng haben wir jemanden, der zum ersten Mal seit fast neun Jahren wieder hier ist. Wir haben damals das Tribünengespräch zu Depressionen im Fußball aufgenommen. Im Dezember 2017. Also ich kann euch beiden nur sehr herzlich danken, dass ihr euch nochmal drauf eingelassen habt. Und es hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch zu sprechen. Vielen Dank euch beiden.
Danke schön.
Und dann will ich ein allerletztes Mal noch auch nochmal die Bücher empfehlen. Ronald Reng, Der deutsche Sommer erschienen bei PIPA. Ronald Reng 1974, Eine deutsche Begegnung. Natürlich auch bei PIPA erschienen. Und dann die Weltmeister von Bern. Ihr habt es gehört, ihr müsst es unbedingt kaufen, wenn das, wenn das dem Verlag schon abgerungen werden musste, dem Rowald Verlag in diesem Fall. Also stürmt zu den Buchhandlungen, besucht Lesungen, wenn es sie in eurer Nähe gibt. Und ansonsten würde ich mich als allerletztes auch freuen, wenn ihr diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt. Denn ihr wisst ja auch, der Rasenfunk wird eben nicht so konsumiert wie ein WM-Finale, ist vielleicht manchmal auch nicht so schlimm. Aber wir freuen uns natürlich auch über Reichweite. Denn alles, was wir hier machen, ist Paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Wir haben unser ganz eigenes Finanzierungsmodell. Der Rasenfunk und all seine Sendungen, die erscheinen, das waren ja allein im letzten Jahr, glaube ich, 300 oder ungefähr um den Dreh rum, die sind von euch finanziert. Durch freiwillige Unterstützung in der Podcast-Beschreibung, der Videobeschreibung oder wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Und dann freuen wir uns, wenn ihr uns Geld zukommen lasst. Ich möchte mich bedanken in dieser Sendung bei Juli, bei Mattis, das mürrische Mammut, bei Benny Zimmer, bei No Look und bei Christoph, Fan der Eintracht Frankfurt. Sie alle haben uns unterstützt und sich auch als Unterstützende registriert. Und deswegen konnte ich sie jetzt hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip auswählen. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge oder Anregungen für weitere unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de ist der perfekte Ort dafür. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr auch in andere Sendungen vom Rasenfunk reinhört. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald. Ciao. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.